nous poursuivrons nos travaux donc sur
le projet loi de finances de 2024 avec
la mission travail et emploi les crédits
sont à l'ordre du jour de la séance
publique le mercredi 15 novembre et nous
examinerons donc les amendements en
commission le mercredi 8 novembre
aujourd'hui nous entendrons monsieur le
ministre Olivier duopte qui nous
présentera les crédits puis notre
rapporteur Stéphane vir pour son analyse
budgétaire et son rapport thématique don
vous avez été destinataire je donnerai
ensuite la parole aux différents
orateurs de groupe pour 4 minutes puis
ensuite les autres députés pourront
poser des questions question pour une
minute chacun je une minute chacun je
passe donc bien tenté monsieur Darville
je passe donc immédiatement la parole à
Monsieur le Ministre monsieur ministre
vous avez la
parole merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les députés je
très heureux de vous vous présenter les
les crédits consacrés à la mission
travail et emploi dans le PLF pour 2024
avec finalement un objectif très simple
qui est celui que poursuit le
gouvernement en matière de politique du
travail et de l'emploi c'est celui
d'atteindre le plein emploi nous avons
déjà fait un bon bout de chemin depuis
ces 6 dernières années vous le savez
nous avons eu l'occasion d'évoquer à
plusieurs reprises le taux de chômage
est un de ces niveaux les plus bas
depuis 40 ans le taux d'emploi est au
niveau le plus haut depuis que l'incel
mesure et nous avons donc mis fin en
espérant évidemment que ce soit durable
et c'est tout l'objet de notre politique
à des décennies de chômage de masse
grâce à une série de de réformes
ambitieuses menées depuis 2017 d'abord
pour l'emploi des jeunes avec la la
réforme de l'apprentissage avec le
contreengagement jeune j'ai eu le
plaisir de signer le le 500000 contrat
il y a quelques jours dans une mission
locale nous avons aussi engagé la la
réforme du lycée professionnel nous
avons souhaité avoir des règles plus
incitatives au retour à l'emploi c'est
l'objet des deux réformes du marché du
travail et de l'assurance chômage que
nous avons mené en 2019 et en 2022 et
nous voulons continuer d'augmenter la
part des seigneurs en emploi c'est
évidemment l'un des effets l'un des
objectifs de la réforme des retraites
mais aussi des des mesures dont nous
souhaitons que les partenaires sociaux
puissent se saisir dans les semaines et
les mois qui viennent dans le cadre d'un
projet d'accord national
interprofessionnel dont nous leur avons
annoncé qu'il serait saisi dans les
prochains jours du du document
d'orientation plus récemment nous avons
voulu nous donner les moyens d'atteindre
le plein emploi en réformant le service
public de l'emploi avec France travail
et pour mettre en place un service
public plus efficace plus coordonné et
un accompagnement renforcé des des plus
éloignés de l'emploi je crois que nous
avons finalement mis un terme à une
forme de de fatalisme ambiant qui a trop
longtemps dominer la question de
l'emploi en France au détriment de ceux
qui sont restés au chômage le plus
longtemps souvent les mêmes et les plus
fragiles entre nous et avec cet objectif
désormais atteignable du du plein emploi
c'est donc un budget tout entier tourné
vers cet objectif que que je vous
présente un budget avec des mesures
fortes et un budget avec des crédits
importants en 2023 ce sont 20,1
milliards d'euros qui étaient inscrit en
autorisation d'engagement et 20,7 en
crédit de paiement pour la loi de
finance initiale et en 2024 nous vous
proposons un budget pour lequel la
mission progresse puisqu'elle atteint
22,4 milliards d'EUR en crédit de
paiement surit une augmentation de 11 %
principalement sous l'effet des dépenses
en faveur de l'apprentissage de France
compétenence ou encore des dispositifs
d'insertion je voudrais d'abord
commencer en disant que les crédits pour
2024 sont cohérents avec la sit la
situation de l'emploi et donc les
dépenses de soutien peuvent s'inscrire
en baisse de manière cohérente avec cet
état du marché du travail l'emploi se
porte bien avec un taux de chômage bas
et un taux d'emploi historique même si
nous avons tous vu et que nous regardons
avec attention les résultats du dernier
trimestre et que nous faisons
extrêmement attention à ce que ces ces
éléments puissent être à la fois suivis
est aussi anticipé que possible ce ce
cycle positif sur le marché de l'emploi
depuis maintenant plusieurs années se
traduit par une réduction du recours aux
allocations de solidarité du programme
102 c'était déjà le cas en 2022 puisquen
fin d'exercice nous avions constaté une
sous-exécution de 415 millions d'euros
au titre principalement de laallocation
de solidarité spécifique par rapport à
la loi de finance initiale et c'est une
dynamique qui prévaut pour 2024 puisque
l'an prochain la baisse du chômage
permet de réduire les dépenses
prévisionnelles pour l'allocation de
solidarité spécifique à 1,7 milliards
d'euros en 2024 soit une baisse de 120
millions d'euros par rapport à la loi de
finance initiale précédente de même
comme c'est le cas depuis 2022 la
dynamique d'activité permet de continuer
d'alléger les dépenses prévisionnelles
pour l'activité partielle qui euh se
chiffreront en 2024 autour de de 200
millions d'euros je veux aussi souligner
que cette augmentation des crédits de la
mission au total traduit clairement une
priorité d'objectif et une priorité
autour de cet objectif de plein emploi
et ce avec plusieurs euh plusieurs buts
et plusieurs chantiers ambitieux pour
l'emploi la formation encore
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
je je je commence en en disant d'abord
qu'en finançant France travail nous
mettons en place un meilleur service
public de l'emploi avec un meilleur
accompagnement pour ceux qui en sont le
plus éloignés et ainsi nous nous
poursuivons cet objectif de créer
d'accompagner la création plus
exactement de 700000 emplois nouveaux
comme nous en avons créé 1lion7 au cours
du du premier quinana de d'Emmanuel
Macron avec France travail nous
proposons d'y parvenir d'une part en
rénovant notre service public de
l'emploi pour qu'il soit plus efficace
et résorber ce problème d'apparillement
du marché du travail nous ne pouvons pas
nous satisfaire d'avoir un taux de
chômage encore aussi élevé alors que les
entreprises connaissent des tensions de
recrutement importantes et d'autre part
avec un investissement social majeur
pour accompagner plus intensément et
pour accompagner un meilleur retour à
l'emploi nous sommes convaincus que
c'est un bon choix un bon choix pour la
cohésion sociale un bon choix aussi pour
les finances publiques puisque au-delà
des questions d'emploi et d'insertion
accompagner les personnes les plus
éloignées moins coûteux que le chômage
augmente l'activité et en retour les
moyens de l'État nous avons donc décidé
comme je l'avais dit lors de du débat
autour du projet de loi pour le plein
emploi d'augmenter les les moyens
consacrés à cet accompagnement et ainsi
dans le cadre de la loi de finances pour
2024 les effectifs de Pol emploi seront
renforcés 300 équivalents en plein pour
permettre l'accompagnement renforcé dans
le cadre de l'élargissement de
l'expérimentation des bénéficiaires du
RSA nous allons aussi stabiliser euh la
subvention de de l'État à l'opérateur
par ailleurs nous allons allouer 170
millions d'euros pour financer la
contractualisation avec les conseils
départementaux contract actualisation
avec tous les conseils départementaux
pour la transition vers France travail
et poursuite de la contractualisation
pour les conseils départementaux
inscrits dans l'expérimentation ou ceux
qui voudrait la rejoindre ces
financements sont en réalité prévus pour
monter en charge de manière progressive
jusqu'à 1 milliard d'euros par an en
2027 et seront financé en partie par un
effort de l'État mais aussi en partie
par les économies permises par la
réforme de l'assurance chômage dans les
gains une partie des gains à
naturellement vocation à être réinvestie
dans l'accompagnement vers l'emploi et
la formation il faut souligner que la
réforme de 2019 l'assurance chômage a
rétabli les les comptes de l'Unedic
puisquils sont excédentaires à hauteur
de 4,4 milliards d'euros en 2022 nous
espérons le même chiffre en 2023 après
10 ans de 2009 à 2019 pendant lesquels
le déficit était en moyenne d'
milillard900 millions d'euros par an
c'est une des deux grande réforme
structurelle avec la réforme des
retraites qui nous permet de réaliser un
certain nombre d'économie permettant le
le financement des des réformes à but de
plein emploi ainsi grâce à
l'augmentation de la contribution de
l'Unedic et grâce au maintien de la
subvention pour charge de service public
de 1,250 milliards d'euros l'opérateur
bénéficiera l'opérateur Pole Emploi
bénéficiera en 2024 de ressources plus
élevées ce qui lui permettra d'affecter
300 millions d'euros au renforcement de
l'accompagnement des des demandeurs
d'emploi dans le cadre de France travail
porté par les 300 ETP que que j'ai
mentionné par ailleurs nous maintenons
un effort très important pour
l'insertion par l'activité économique
euh d'abord l'insertion en faveur des
jeunes avec un objectif de 300000
contrats d'engagement jeune pour l'année
2024 comme en 2023 nous inscrivons aussi
un ,5 milliards d'euros d'autorisation
d'engagement et de crédit de paiement
pour la trajectoire d'insertion par
l'activité économique plus
traditionnelle cela permettra à minima
structure par structure d'avoir un
financement pour le même nombre de
postes que celui réalisé en 2023 mais
aussi de financer un certain nombre de
développement et d'augmentation sur
l'ensemble du du territoire de la même
manière c'est le deuxième point que je
souhaitais souligner nous poursuivons
notre objectif de développement de
l'apprentissage nous considérons que
cette cette politique de développement
volontariste de l'alternance et de
l'apprentissage AG est efficace pour
intégrer et former les jeunes et que le
succès deapprentissage est frappant tant
pour les jeunes que leurs familles ou
les entreprises si ont recours ainsi ENP
en dépit de la crise sanitaire et du
contexte macroéconomique qui a suivi
avec l'inflation le nombre d'entrées
dans le dispositif pour le secteur privé
a connu un doublement entre 2019 et 2022
en passant de près de 360000 contrats
d'apprentissage signés en 201 en 2019 à
plus de 840000 en en 2022 donc nous
maintenons cet engagement majeur en
faveur de l'apprentissage et toujours
cet objectif d'atteindre 1 million
d'apprentis 1 million de de contrat
d'apprentissage par an d'ici la fin du
quinquena nous le faisons en conduisant
des des mesures rationalisation du
fonctionnement des centres de formation
des apprentis bien sûr et nous le
faisons avec des crédits de paiement qui
s'élèvent pour le PLF 2024 pour ce qui
concerne l'aide à les aides à l'emboche
d'alternant à 3,9 milliards d'euros et
par ailleurs nous inscrivons une
dotation budgétaire de 2,5 milliards
d'euros dès la loi de finan initiale
pour soutenir France compéten et l'aider
à faire face aux dépenses ainsi
engendrées je je sais que parfois il y a
des interrogations sur les paramètres
des primes à l'emboche des apprentis
mais je dis très clairement le
gouvernement n'est pas favorable à une
modification des paramètres des primes à
l'apprentissage en 2024 le montant de la
prime sera donc le même qu'en 2023 dans
le projet de de loi présentée par le
gouvernement 6000 € pour l'emboche d'un
apprenti quelle que soit la taille de
l'entreprise et quel que soit le niveau
de formation de de l'apprentissage nous
ne souhaitons pas casser la dynamique ni
envoyer un contresignal qui serait
néfaste au développement de de
l'apprentissage ce budget concernant
l'apprentissage nous le pilotons aussi
en faisant appliquer des mesures qui
garantissent la soutenabilité financière
du système avec une responsabilisation
des organisme et un renforcement des
exigences de qualité des certifications
éligiblebl au CPF c'est intervenu dès
septembre 2022 avec une révision des
niveaux de prise en charge des contrats
des coûts de contrat d'apprentissage et
et des coûts de formation ces mesures
dégagent des économies substantielles
qui s'élève à 1 milliard d'euros pour
les mesures de régulation sur le CPF et
à 840 millions d'euros sur sur la prise
en charge des des le niveau de prise en
charge des coûts de formation n nous
travaillons aussi vous le savez nous
l'avons nous l'avons pas mise en œuvre
en 2023 considérant qu'il y avait une
moindre urgence mais nous travaillons à
une forme de participation de certains
des bénéficiaires du CPF la loi de
finances pour 2023 a prévu le vecteur
juridique et nous y travaillerons au
début de l'année 2024 pour un certain
nombre de de formations par ailleurs
pour ce qui concerne la formation
notamment la formation continue nous
allons continuer d'investir massivement
dans celle-ci le le succès du plan d'in
ement dans les compétences entre 2018 et
2023 nous permet de le reconduire avec
la certitude que le retour à l'emploi
d'une part et la réponse au besoins des
entreprises d'autre part passe par la
formation ainsi pour 2024 au titre du
plan d'investissement dans les
compétences ce sont 1,4 milliards
d'euros de nouveaux engagements de
l'État ainsi qu'une contribution de 800
millions d'euros de France compéten ce
qui nous permettra de financer les
pactes régionaux d'investissement dans
les compétences à hauteur d'1,1 milliard
d'euros les négociations sont ouvertes
avec les régions pour déterminer les les
pactes régionaux d'invest dans les
compétences pour la période 2024 2000
2027 dans la même logique nous
souhaitons continuer de répondre aux
besoins de compéten des entreprises qui
vont aller croissant notamment du fait
de la transition écologique et numérique
et si nous avons déjà réorienté le F no
formation il est réorienté puisqu'il
n'est plus réservé aux entreprises en
difficulté en activité partielle ou en
mutation mais qu'il peut désormais
bénéficier à des formations liées au
transition écologique alimentaire et
numérique nous avons inscrit 273
millions d'euros sur ce dispositif au
titre du élèves 2024 enfin nous
continuons nos efforts pour un emploi de
de meilleure qualité évidemment les
sommes ne sont pas les mêmes nous
travaillons sur des questions de
communication de fonctionnement de
certaines agences et opérateurs c'est le
cas notamment en matière de prévention
des accidents du travail gravé mortel
nous pré nous prévoyons aussi à la suite
de de nos négociations pardon avec les
partenaires sociaux d'augmenter de 2,17
millions la contribution annuelle de
l'État au fond paritaire national qui
finance les organisations syndicales et
patronales pour le renforcement et le
développement du dialogue social avec
des élections professionnelles qui
arrivent et qui nécessitent cette
mobilisation enfin nous souhaitons en
202 en 2024 augmenter la la subvention
de de l'État l'Agence nationale pour
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
l'anaacte en la revalorisation en la
revalorisant pardon de 1,5 million
d'euros pour passer de 9,7 à 11,2
million d'euros pour accompagner la
réorganisation d'établissement et
l'intégration des associations
régionales mais aussi faciliter le
déploiement de de ces politiques de
prévention si vous me permettez monsieur
le Président je termine par l'évolution
des moyens affectés au ministère pour la
mise en œuvre de ces politiques au total
les les crédits du programme 155 qui est
le programme support du ministère du
Travail vont augmenter de 18 millions
d'euros en 2024 et s'agissant des moyens
humains je souligne devant votre
commission que le PLF pour 2024 prévoit
la stabilité des effectifs des services
du ministère du travail c'est la 2è
année sur les 14 dernières mais c'est la
2uxème année que nous avons une
stabilité des effectifs et la loi de
programmation pluriannuelle des finances
publiques prévoit une stabilité des
effectifs jusqu'à la fin du quinen ainsi
nous aurons un plafond d'emploi en 2024
fixé à
7799 équivalent en plein et le schéma
d'emploi est très légèrement positif de
quelques dizaines d'unités sur les deux
dernières années nous avons ainsi obtenu
le maintien des 105 emplois autorisés en
2023 pour le recrutement des délégués à
l'accompagnement des reconversions
professionnelles au sein des directions
régionales et départemental nous allons
pouvoir aussi créer une trentaine de
postes dans les directions régionales
pour accompagner le le déploiement du
réseau France travail et et ainsi
témoigner d'un soutien renforcé à nos
services déconcentrés je précise aussi
que 2024 sera marqué par la fin des
transferts d'effectifs opérés dans le
cadre de la réforme de l'organisation
territoriale de l'État ce qui correspond
à 120 ETP qui sont ainsi conservés et
pour la première année indépendamment
des mouvements internes au ministère du
Travail il n'y aura pas de restitution
des effectifs par les services
déconcentrés ce qui est aussi je crois
une une bonne nouvelle en terme de
stabilité le budget de masse salariale
prévu pour 2024 s'élève à 580 77,6
million d'euros soit une augmentation de
15 millions d'euros ce qui permet de
financer les mesures de pouvoir d'achat
décidé pour l'ensemble des agents
publics en en juillet 2023 je pense à à
la revalorisation générale du point
d'indice de 1.5 à l'attribution de 9
points d'indice supplémentaires pour les
bas salaires de 5 points d'indice à à
tous les agents à compter du 1er janvier
2024 au remboursement de 75 % du forfait
de transport collectif à compter de
septembre 2023 compte 50 % au paravant
ou encore la majoration de 10 % de
l'indemnisation des des jours de cet à
compter du 1er janvier 24 enens j'ajoute
une enveloppe de 4 million d'euros pour
des mesures indemnitaires en faveur de
l'attractivité des ministères et
notamment du service de l'inspection du
travail et je me réjouis que les
premiers éléments de cette politique de
renforcement de l'attractivité du corps
d'inspection porte ses fruits puisque le
le nombre d'inscrits admis au concours
admis à concourir au concours de
l'Inspection du travail en 2023 augmente
de 24 % par rapport à à 2022 avec plus
500+ 359 inscrits admis à concourir que
nous avons 280 élèves admissible pour
200 places contre 120 élèves dans la
promotion précédente et par ailleurs
comme en 2023 nous avons ouvert 200
places au concours sans place par des
recrutements détachement et pour la
première fois depuis 5 ans maintenant
les effectifs de l'inspection du travail
ont au mois d'août 2023 connu une
évolution à la hausse par rapport au
trimestre précédent ce qui rond avec
plusieurs années de diminution euh
systématique et consécutive du nombre
d'inspecteurs affectés à ces contrôles
d'inspection voilà Monsieur le président
ce que je pouris dire pour présenter les
les crédits de la mission emploi et
travail merci monsieur le ministre pour
ces précisions je donne la parole à
Monsieur Stéphane viri rapporteur
thématique merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
donc la discussion de la mission travail
et emploi du projet loi de finances pour
2024 intervient dans un contexte
économique favorable pour l'emploi à
plusieurs égards d'une part notre pays
connaît l'un des plus bas taux de
chômage depuis 40 ans d'autre part des
politiques publiques ambitieuses pour
parvenir au plein emploi son mise en
œuvre depuis plusieurs années la
dernière end date étant la création
d'une nouvel opérateur France travail
dont le déplo le déploiement progressif
à partir de 2024 est financé par les
crédits de la de la présente mission
budgétaire je voudrais commencer mon
propos en faisant quelques remarques sur
les crédit affectés à l'émission travail
emploi dont la hausse de 2,6 milliards
d'euros en autorisation d'engagement et
de 1,7 milliard d'euros en crédit de
paiement elle est significative mais
avant toute chose je voudrais vous faire
part monsieur le ministre de ma
préoccupation au regard du retard avec
lequel les réponses du gouvernement aux
questions que j'ai posé au début de
l'été me sont parvenues en effet le 10
octobre date à laquelle les réponses
doivent être transmises aux rapporteurs
spéciaux et pour avis en application de
la LOF nous n'avions reçu qu'un tiers
seulement des questions des réponses aux
questions posées 3 mois pour attendre
des éléments permettant à un
parlementaire de faire son travail dans
le cadre du travail de la confrontation
institutionnelle entre l'exécutif et
législa tif je déplore la façon de
procéder de l'administration dans le
cadre de de ces débats budgétaires il va
s'en dire évidemment que l'absence de
réponse à ces questions est un droit du
rapporteur dans l'exercice de ses
prérogatives auxquels je suis très
attaché passer cette observation très
personnelle mais très très importante à
mes yeux j'en viens au crédit et
notamment au programme 102 accès et
retour à l'emploi qui a pour pour
objectif de favoriser l'accès et le
retour à l'emploi des demandeurs
d'emploi dont le niveau est en
diminution
du fait de l'amélioration de la de la
situation du marché du travail néanmoins
la sous-action consacrée au financement
du service public de l'emploi voit ses
crédits substantiellement croître plus
170 % en autorisation d'engagement plus
300 % en crédit de paiement afin de
consacrer 170 millions d'euros
supplémentaires à la transition de Pôle
Emploi vers l'opérateur France travail
et à la poursuite des expérimentation
relative à l'accompagnement renforcé des
bénéficiaires du RSA ce sont également
300 ettpt additionnels qui seront
déployés en 2024 pour faire face à la
montée en puissance desémissions du
nouvel opérateur je salue naturellement
et bien entendu ces moyens
supplémentaires indispensablebl à la
réussite d'un service public de l'emploi
plus efficace et résolument tourné vers
les plus éloignés de l'emploi dans la
continuité des années précédentes le
gouvernement fait le choix au sein de du
programme 102 de diminuer le nombre de
contrats le nombre d'entrées pardon en
contrat aidé réduit à 66700 parcours
emploi compéten les PEC et 15000
contrats d'initiative emploi les Cie en
2024 soit 800700 contrats aidés un
objectif je le signale fort éloigné des
459000 contrat aidés encore observés en
2016 j'eneviens monsieur le ministre à
ma première question j'aurais aimé
connaître votre avis sur l'intérêt des
contrats aidés pour parvenir au plein
emploi pensez-vous notamment que cette
baisse constatée année après année est
amenée à se poursuivre tout au long de
ce quinquena j'enviens à au programme
103 avec une hausse des crédits qui est
très largement portée par la dynamique
des aides aux employeurs d'apprentis qui
augmente de 1,8 milliards d'euros en
autorisation d'engagement et 300000
millions en crédit de paiement dans la
mesure où nous partageons votre objectif
d'atteindre 1 million d'apprentis par
par an d'ici 2027 nous approuvons bien
entendu le financement de cette montée
en puissance j'en viens au crédit des
programmes 111 et 155 s'agissant des des
crédits du programme 111 amélioration de
la qualité de l'emploi et des relations
de travail je comprends que leur hausse
est essentiellement liée à
l'organisation du scrutin TPE en fin
d'année 2024 et au renouvellement des
mesures de représentativité patr
patronnale et syndicale au 1er janvier
2025 elle me semble en ce sens tout à
fait normale et légitime concernant les
crédits du programme 155 conception
gestion et évaluation des politiques de
l'emploi du travail qui appuie et
soutient les politiques publiques du
ministère du travail du plein emploi de
l'insertion je constate que la hausse
est d d'une part à l'augmentation des
dépenses de personnel qui représente 85
% des crédit et d'autre part au moyens
supplémentaires dédiés à la
communication et au système
d'information cette haosse n'appelons
pas de commentaires particulierers voilà
les quelques remarques que je souhaitais
faire sur l'évolution des crédits à
travers cet avis budgétaire j'ai
souhaité aborder un premier sujet qui
est celui de la privation d'emploi au
travers de l'expérimentation territoire
zéro chômeurs durée en préambule je
souhaite rappeler que ce projet n'est
pas resté contonné à notre pays en
Autriche en Belgique des territoires ont
déjà fait l'objet d'une expérimentation
similaire tandis que Rome a engagé dans
l'a engagé pardon dans deux quartiers
alors que notre exemple inspire vous le
voyez mes chers collègues il
apparaîtrait pour le moins paradoxal de
réduire le soutien de l'État à un
programme qui a déjà prouvé son
efficacité c'est pourtant l'inquiétude
exprimée par l'associ l'association
gestionnaire du fond d'expérimentation
et que nous serons nombreux je n'en
doute pas à relayer ici adopter à deux
reprises à l'unanimité des membres du
Parlement l'expérimentation dont le
cadre actuel est issu de de la loi du 14
décembre 2020 permet à des personne
durablement éloigné de l'emploi de
retrouver un travail stable dans une
entreprise utile à son territoire tout
en générant des économies pour la
collectivité nous sommes très attachés à
ce dispositif dont l'extension à 60
territoires permettra d'évaluer les
principes qui le régissent il m'est donc
apparu pertinent d'évaluer avec les
données partielles dont nous disposons
l'adéquation des moyens budgétaires aux
ambitions qu'il pent je regrette je je
le redit je regrette cependant qu'à ce
jour le gouvernement ne m'it pas
transmis les réponses à mes à mon
questionnaire budgétaire concernant ce
sujet de préoccupation majeure pour
l'ensemble des
parlementaires le manque de
considération pour notre travail ne
participe pas à apaiser les inquiétudes
légitimes quant à l'avenir de cette
expérimentation j'en viiens mes chers
collègues à présent au crédit inscrit
dans le PLF 2024 qui font l'objet et je
m'en réjouis d'une augmentation de plus
de 50 % par rapport à l'an passé avec
près de 69 millions d'euros en
autorisation de en AE pardon et en et en
CP cette hausse faut-il le dire cette
Haos significative atteste de soutien de
état a un dispositif utile parmi nos
outils pour lutter contre le chômage de
longue durée elle doit cependant être
mise en regard de la dynamique de
l'expérimentation qui se poursuivra tout
au long de l'année 2024 avec la création
de 1091 ETP supplémentaires selon les
données fournies par le gouvernement
l'association gestionnaire du fond
conteste ces projections et considère
que le niveau de dotation inscrit dans
le PLF est insuffisant vous le savez mes
chers collègues l'expérimentation
garantie en effet à tous les demandeurs
d'emploi volontaire résidants dans le
territoire de bénéficier d'un contrat à
durée indéterminé à temps choisi selon
l'association ce sont plus de 1916 ETP
supplémentaires qui devront être
financés en 2024 soit deux fois plus que
les estimations du gouvernement il est
donc à mes yeux nécessaire d'envoyer un
signal clair à destination de tous les
porteurs de projet quant au soutien de
l'État aux emplois qu'ils onend de créer
pour ma part je le dis je suis favorable
à la demande portée par l'association de
réhausser de 20 millions d'euros les
crédits investis tel que cela a pu être
voté déjà hier en commission des
finances en tout état de cause monsieur
le ministre pouvez-vous nous assurer que
le soutien de l'État permettra en 2024
de recruter l'ensemble des demandeurs
d'emploi de longue durée volontaire dans
les territoire habilité où en passe de
lettre c'est ma deè question s'agissant
de l'expri entation et du financement je
tiens à rappeler qu'il doit être comparé
au coût du chômage de longue durée en
terme d'allocation pour la personne mais
aussi d'être diverse pour son foyer
ainsi qu'aux recettes que celle-ci
permet de générer au regard ou à travers
de l'acroissement du pouvoir d'achat des
personnes concernées et des retombées
économiques positifes pour le territoire
et il appartiendra ainsi au comité
d'évaluation de déterminer le coût net
du dispositif monsieur le ministre c'est
ma trème question pouvez-vous nous
confirmer que le comité scientifique est
désormais en capacité de réaliser ce
travail
d'évaluation du reste un certain et moi
s'est fait connaître depuis cet été
puisque le gouvernement a annoncé un
recul du financement des salariés dans
les entreprises à but d'emploi les EBE
dont le taux de prise en charge est
passé au 1er octobre de 102 à 95 % du
SMIC si pour ma part je souscris à
l'objectif du
gouvernement d'inciter les EBE à
développer un modèle économique plus
robuste en augmentant leur part
d'autofinancement il me semble pour
autant que c'est un mauvais signal qu'il
aurait envoyé dans une phase d'expansion
de l'expérimentation et qui risque de
mettre en difficulté un certain nombre
d'entreprises le risque est tout
simplement de les priver de trésoreries
alors que ces entreprises en ont besoin
tout en ne permettant pas de réaliser
des économies substantielles pour l'État
puisqueune subvention d'équilibre
viendra compenser en fin d'exercice
l'éventuel
déficit enfin en ce qui concerne la
avenir de l'expérimentation au
territoire gérau chôur longue durée il
est à mes yeux encore un peu tôt pour
déterminer le contenu de la troème loi
que j'appelle toutefois de mes vœux
néanmoins il me paraît essentiel de
tirer les enseignements des deux des
premières années de ce dispositif outre
leur capacité à atteindre des personnes
inconnues du service public de l'emploi
l'un des intérêts principaux des
territoires gérau chômeurs par rapport à
des structures classique d'insertion par
l'activité économique et la possibilité
pour les demandeurs d'emploi de
bénéficier d'un comp contrat à durée
indéterminée cette stabilité leur permet
de lever progressivement les freins
périphériques tout en retrouvant la
sérénité nécessaire à un éventuel retour
sur le marché du travail il me semble
donc nécessaire de s'intéresser à
l'avenir de ses salariés au sein ou à
l'extérieur des EBE en les accompagnant
de leur projet professionnels tout au
long de leur parcours mes chers
collègues le second sujet que j'ai
souhaité aborder dans cet avis
budgétaire c'est celui de l'insertion
professionnelle et sociale par le sport
à laquelle je crois ferme depuis
longtemps mais comme beaucoup j'observe
que pour tirer pleinement des
opportunités qu'offrent le sport dans le
domaine de l'emploi il y a lieu de faire
évoluer l'intervention de l'État afin
qu'elle devienne plus claire et plus
efficace c'est l'objet de la feuille de
route relative au développement de
l'emploi et de l'insertion par et dans
le sport signé le 7 novembre 2022 par le
ministre du Travail la ministre des
Sports et la ministre déléguée à
l'enseignement et à la formation
professionnelle qui est battu autour de
cinq axes tout d'abord l'amélioration de
la lisibilité de l'offre de formation et
de certification deuxièmement la
simplification de l'accès au dispositif
d'emploi et à la sécurisation des
trajectoires professionnelles
troisièmement le renforcement du rôle
social des acteurs du sport
quatrièmement la reconnaissance des
parcours et des compétence de le dans le
sport et enfin 5e axe la reconversion
des sportifs de haut niveau cette
feuille de route contient un ensemble de
mesures complétées par les mesures
annoncées lors du Grenel de l'emploi et
des métiers du sport qui doivent
permettre de satisfaire l'ambition
consistant dans la création de 100000
nouveaux emplois et dans la
multiplication par 5 des bénéficiir des
actions d'insertion par et dans le sport
d'ici la fin du d'ici la fin du kakena
c'est un très bel objectif je voudrais
toutefois évoquer ici quelques-uns des
objectifs qui soutendent les quatre
premiers axes et en profiter pour
interroger le ministre sur un certain
nombre de points premièrement pour
améliorer la lisibilité de l'offre et
des parcours de formation les les
ministres et les partenaires sociaux se
sont engagés à simplifier et à mettre en
cohérence les formations et les
certifications en créant un référentiel
commun des métiers des compétences et
des qualifications d'une part et en
concevant les certifications sous forme
de bloc de compéten d'autre part c'est
une réelle avancée car les diplômes et
les certifications dans le secteur du
sport sont trop nombreux 900
certifications actuellement sont environ
répertoriés quand 350 d'entre elles sont
actives et inscrites au répertoire na
le référentiel que j'ai mentionné doit
avir le jour cet automne monsieur le
ministre pouvez-vous aujourd'hui
confirmer que tel sera bien le cas
deuxièmement pour simplifier l'accès au
dispositifs d'emploi et sécuriser les
trajectoires professionnelles la feuille
de route prévoit plusieurs actions parmi
lesquels l'amélioration de
l'articulation des dispositifs et le
développement d'outils de communication
destinés à les rendre plus visibles
monsieur le ministre là encore pouvezv
pouvez-vous nous donner des précisions
sur l'état d'avancement de ces deux
chantiers plus généralement quel bilan
le ministère du Travail fait-il en ce
qui concerne l'efficacité des
dispositifs en question je pense
notamment à sésam aux employés de
l'Agence nationale du sport ou à
l'apprentissage dans le sport
troisièmement enfin pour pour renforcer
le rôle social des acteurs du sport qui
n'est plus à démontrer le ministère du
travail apporte avec d'autres un soutien
financier à certains projets innovants à
l'initiative baptisé les clubs
s'engagent les clubs sportifs engagés
pardon tout d'abord 1 million d'euros en
autorisation d'engagement en crédit de
paiement ils sont consacrés dans le PLF
pour 2024 selon les prévisions du
gouvernement l'initiative devrait réunir
10000 clubs d'ici la fin de l'année
prochaine je forme le vœux monsieur le
ministre que ce cet objectif soit
atteint ensuite aux opérations du stade
vers l'emploi ces opérations
mobiliseront des crédits portés par le
ministère du Travail à hauteur de 690000
€ en autorisation d'engagement et 280000
€ en crédit de paiement et des crédits
portés par d'autres financeurs comme le
Ministère des Sports pour un montant
égal à 2,1 million d'euros du stade vers
l'emploi mes chers collègues est une
méthode de recrutement novatrice basée
sur l'organisation par les fédérations
sportives en association étroite avec
Pôle Emploi d'événements de mise en
relation de demandeurs d'emploi et
d'employeur par le sport les premiers
résultats sont encourageants néanmoins
les critères d'évaluation à ce stade
sont encore trop parcellaires et je
souhaiterais monsieur le ministre savoir
si le gouvernement envisage de procéder
à une évaluation du dispositif ce qui me
paraît indispensable contte tenu du
montant des crédits qui lui sont dévolu
quatrièmement pour favoriser la
reconnaissance des compétences dans le
sport le gouvernement souhaite que le
nombre de bénéficiaires d'action de
validation des acquis de de l'expérience
VAE soit porté à 2400 en
2024 j'ai pour ma part la conviction que
la VAE peut jouer un rôle décisif dans
la consolidation des parcours
professionnels en particulier des
personnes les moins diplômées je partage
donc là au corp monsieur le ministre
l'ambition du gouvernement dans ce ce
domaine et enfin mes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre je terminerai par
un constat aujourd'hui la multiplicité
des acteurs institutionnels qui
promeuvent qui accompagne qui finance
des dispositifs d'insertion par le sport
rend difficile l'appréhension et le
suivi de l'action public en la matière
je m'interroge sur les solutions
susceptibles d'être misise en œuvre pour
remédier à cette difficulté quoi qu'il
en soit l'une des traduction de cet état
de faite c'est qu'il est malaisé de
disposer d'une vision exhaustive de
l'effort budgétaire senti par l'État
pouvez-vous nous indiquer monsieur le
ministre le montant total des crédits
portés par le ministère du Travail pour
financer l'ensemble des actions
d'insertion par et dans le sport voilà
les quelques observations que je voulais
faire en tant que rapporteur pour avis
sur les crédits de la mission travail
emploi pour 2024 je voudrais très
sincèrement et naturellement remercier
les administrateurs qui m'ont accompagné
pour préparer cet avis de grande qualité
avec beaucoup de précision et avec une
disponibilité très constante je vous
merci mes chers collègues merci monsieur
le rapporteur nous allons passer
maintenant aux différents orateurs de
groupe et donc je donne la parole à
Monsieur Didier lea pour le groupe
renéence pour 4 minutes oui merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues l'évolution du budget de la
mission travail et emploi du PLF 2024
traduit donc la priorité donnée par le
gouvernement au plein emploi et au
renforcement de l'accompagnement des
bénéficiaaires du RSA et des personnes
les plus éloignées du marché du travail
en ce sens les crédits de la mission
travail et emploi du LF 2024 budgétise
et concrétise les politiques
gouvernementales adoptées par notre
assemblée à commencé par le projet de
loi pour le plein emploi voté le 10
octobre dernier au-delà même les crédits
de la mission travail et emploi
traduisent donc la volonté de la
majorité depuis 2017 d'augmenter
l'attractivité du travail dans notre
pays de combattre le chômage de masse et
de développer la formation par
alternance ces crédits qui représentent
au total 22,7 milliards d'euros en
autorisation engagement et 22,4
milliards en crédit de paiement
progresse ainsi de 11 % par rapport à
2023 rappelons que ce budget s'inscrit
dans un contexte désormais connu avec un
taux de chômage de 7,2 soit l'un des
plus bas niveau depuis 40 ans et a un
taux d'emploi de 68,6 des 1564 ans soit
le plus élevé depuis 1975 mais rappelons
cependant que encore beaucoup de nos
concitoyens reste durablement éloigné du
marché du travail la traduction de la
politique gouvernementale en en faveur
de l'emploi se lit dans les programmes
102 103 111 et 155 de la mission travail
et emploi les programmes 102 et 103 euh
représente à eu de les budgets
structurant l'intervention publique sur
le marché du travail autour du TripTic
Emploi Formation accompagnement auquel
nous sommes particulièrement attachés
c'est pourquoi la mission travail et
emploi du PLF 2024 verra-t-elle le
renforcement des effectifs de France
travail Pôle emploi avec 300 équivalents
temps plein créant en 2024 pour mieux
accompagner les bénéficiaires du RSA
ainsi que ça a été rappelé par Monsieur
le Ministre l'allocation de 170 millions
d'euros de crédit au renforcement de la
contractualisation avec les conseils
départementaux dans le cadre de la mise
en œuvre de France travail pour répondre
à l'ambition d'une société de plein
emploi je ne peux donc que me réjouir du
maintien en 2024 par le gouvernement des
efforts en direction des populations et
des territoires les plus
fragiles ainsi en 2024 sera poursuivi la
politique en faveur de l'insertion des
personnes les plus éloignées de l'emploi
avec 1,5 milliards euh pour l'IAE
l'insertion par l'activité économique en
faveur des jeunes avec un objectif de
300000 contrats d'emploi jeunes ou
encore en faveur des personnes en
situation de handicap avec des mesures
cohérentes avec celles annoncées lors de
la Conférence nationale du handicap du
26 avril
2023 sur ce sujet et comme en réponse
aux inquiétudes de monsieur le
rapporteur je rappelle que l'État pour
2024 abondra auteur de 69 millions
d'euros l'expérimentation territoire
zéro chômeurs soit une augmentation de
plus de 24 millions la formation des
demandurs d'emploi via un nouveau plan
d'investissement pour les compétences
contractualisées avec les régions elle
est budgeté à hauteur de 3,9 milliards
d'euros avec un ciblage prioritaire des
formations vers les demandeurs d'emploi
sans bac ou sans diplôme de niveau bac +
2 les bénéficiaaires du RSA et les
travailleurs en situation de handicap
ainsi que les seniors afin de poursuivre
le développement de l'alternance et
atteindre l'objectif d'un million
d'apprentis en 2027 le programme 103
maintient l'aide à l'embauche
d'alternant porté à 3,9 milliards
d'euros enfin concernant le programme
111 améliorer amélioration de la qualité
de l'emploi et des relations du travail
on ne peut que se satisfaire de la
hausse de près de 14 % des autorisations
d'engagement en faveur de la santé et de
la sécurité au travail ainsi en 202
concernant la prévention des risques
professionnels et l'amélioration des
conditions de travail il faut rappeler
qu'au 1er janvier 2023 l'ancte a intégré
les 16 associations régionales et leurs
180 équivalent temps plein pour
renforcer la prévention en santé au
travail aussi pour vous monsieur le
minist nous détailler les missions nous
détailler un peu plus les missions et
les moyens de l'ancte qui a vocation à
jouer un rôle majeur dans la mise en
place du Plan Santé au Travail et bien
évidemment pour conclure je rappellerai
que notre groupe votera bien évidemment
les crédits de cette mission merci merci
chers collègues pour le rassemblement
national monsieur Christophe
Benz merci Monsieur le le président
monsieur le ministre comme à chaque
nouveau texte portant sur l'emploi nous
sommes toujours plein plein d'espoir qui
laisse rapidement place à la à la
désillusion comme d'habitude rien sur
les salaires question pourtant centrale
pour les Français qui subissent chaque
mois une perte progressive de leur
pouvoir d'achat rien non plus sur le
maintien et l'accès à l'emploi pour les
seniors alors même que vous leur
demandez de travailler plus et plus
longtemps vous auriez pourtant pu
allouer à cet effet une partie des fonds
destinés à France
travail la création de France travail
c'est vous qui l'avez confirmé c'est 1,2
25 milliards dont 470 millions d'euros
pour aller fliquer si vous me permettez
l'expression les bénéficiaires du RSA
autant d'argent qui aurait pu être
utilisé ailleurs autant d'argent qui
aurait pu être alloué au bien-être et
aux conditions de travail par exemple
mais non rien rien alors que près d'un
salarié sur deux a pris un arrêt de
travail en 2022 contre un sur 3 en 2019
rien alors que la France est le 4e pays
de l' où il y a le plus d'accidents du
travail mortel rien alors que 34 % des
salariés disent subir une triple
contrainte physique et que 35 % d'entre
eux affirment souffrir de contraintes de
rythme dans leur travail vous vous
contentez de vous concentrer sur les
fautes individuelles en revalorisant le
montant d' démité journalière mais rien
sur le sens général du travail et
l'amélioration des conditions d'exercice
des travailleurs après l'échec de votre
article sur les accidents du travail et
maladies professionnelles dans le PLFSS
euh il est déplorable de voir que rien
n'est prévu dans ce PLF l'objectif du
plein emploi que votre gouvernement
cherche à atteindre se fait aujourd'hui
au détriment des conditions de travail
et du bien-être des travailleurs ce qui
n'est pas acceptable sur le plan social
et humain alors Monsieur le Ministre ma
question est simple quand allez-vous
enfin écouter les Français qui
travaillent et cessz de considérer la
question du travail et de l'emploi
uniquement sous le prisme financier je
vous
remercie merci pour la France insoumise
monsieur Adrien
Clouet merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre alors on discute
aujourd'hui du marché du travail hein
c'est-à-dire le lieu essentiel où se
joue la dignité humaine puisque c'est là
qu'on peut accéder à un emploi et donc
une contrepartie monétaire laquelle
permet de subvenir à ses besoins et à
ceux de ses proches dès lors discuter du
budget consacré aux politiques d'emploi
c'est discuter de l'accès des individus
à leur dignité individuelle et
collective mais malheureusement tenir
cette discussion le jour d'Halloween
semble un heureux hasard vu le contexte
dans lequel elle se déroule d'abord
votre réforme France travail va conduire
à l'inscription de millions de personnes
en plus auprès du service public
d'emploi ces inscrits nouveaux
s'ajoutent à des populations d'ors et
déjà prise en charge qui augmente
puisque nous avons 20000 inscrites et
inscrits en plus à Pôle Emploi ce
mois-ci pour les chanceuses et chanceux
qui ne seraient pas pris en charge par
service public d'emploi pas de bol les
salaires ont baissé de 1,8 % en un an
dit autrement et ceux qui nous écoutent
et font 35 he par semaine doivent bien
comprendre que leur rémunération en
moyenne a conduit à ce qu'il travaillent
une demi-heure gratuite par semaine par
rapport à au prix auquel éta rémunéré
leur force de travail au début de
l'année drôle de manière d'inciter au
travail comme disait le collègue à
l'instant ce n'est pas évidemment un
phénomène naturel ou hasardeux c'est
votre politique qui vise explicitement
épargne salarial prime Macron chaque
inflation vous avez décidé que la
rémunération du travail prendrait toutes
les formes possibles sauf celle du
salaire car celui selui-ci a pour défaut
à vos yeux de financer la sécurité
sociale dès lors vous avez opté pour le
493 mensuel sur les fiches de paye quant
au taux d'emploi que vous évoquiez il
augmente certes puisque vous maintenez
de force les seniors qui ne quittent
plus le marché du travail par le biais
de la pension de retraite mais par le
chômage le handicap ou la blessure ce
qui me paraît être un acquis social tout
à fait discutable puisque les gens sont
mis dans des emplois de mauvaise qualité
en raison de votre politique la
productivité même du travail recule
c'est-à-dire que dans notre pays on
produit de moins en moins par heure de
travail phénomène totalement inédit dans
l'histoire à part des situations de
guerre puisque depuis 2019 la
productivité du travail a reculé de 4 %.
alors nous avons ici un programme Accès
retour à l'emploi qui peut-être pourrait
se saisir de ces problématiques
malheureusement ce n'est pas le cas le
budget apparent évolue de - 0,15 % mais
c'est évidemment une entourloupe
puisqueavec l'inflation c'est - 6 en
terme réel comment arri-t-on à cette
situation d'abord vous baissez de 280
millions d'euros depuis l'année dernière
inclus le budget la dotation pardon
attribuée à Pôle emploi ou France
travail ce qui représente l'équivalent
de 6000 postes de conseillère ou de
conseiller et c'est pas faute évidemment
de siphonner les comptes de l'unidic
puisque vous y récupérez maintenant 15 %
des recettes de l'assurance chômage
situation tout à fait rocambolesque dès
lors que des salariés çaquit d'une
contribution pour le propre accès à
l'emploi puis euh une fois que le
service public d'emploi était saccagé
vous supprimez les contrats aidé on l'a
bien vu d'ailleurs ça a été revendiqué à
l'instant vous privilégiez
l'apprentissage pourquoi et bien parce
que l'apprentissage s'accompagne
d'effets d'è c'està-dire qu'une
entreprise lucrative recrute en
apprentissage les mêmes personnes que le
recrué sans les aides mais elle empoche
évidemment les aides au passage dès lors
la on comprend mieux pourquoi la moitié
des contrats d'insertion emploi jeune
disparaissent et on comprend mieux
pourquoi dans le même temps
l'apprentissage s'adresse désormais au
diplômé postbac qui constitue les 2/3 de
l'effectif quant à l'expérimentation de
territoire zéro chômeurs de longue durée
elle est abandonnée les crédits
paraissent augmenter comme a dit le
collègue Le Gac à l'instant de 45 à 68
millions d'Ur EUR mais c'est uniquement
sous l'effet du la hausse du nombre de
territoires habilités ce qui a
visiblement trompé notre collègue
puisque la contribution au développement
de l'emploi versée par l'État passe de
102 à 95 % du SMIC heureusement hier
nous avons rajouté 51 million d'euros à
cette action pour les territoires zéro
chômeurs de longue durée et on espère
que malgré le 493 à venir vous saurez
entendre une majorité sur à peu près
tous les bancs de l'Assemblée nationale
alors soyons juste il y a des cadeaux
170 millions de niche fiscale comme la
déduction forfaitaire sur les heures sup
ou un triplement enfin pardon une
augmentation des dépenses de
communication triplement l'année
dernière Haus de 5,72 % cette année mais
le problème monsieur le ministre n'est
pas le la manière de communiquer c'est
le contenu de la
communication merci pour les
républicains Monsieur Philippe
Juvin merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre bon tout d'abord la
la situation sur le le le le plan de
l'emploi s'améliore évidemment en France
les chiffres sont là mais je pense qu'il
faut moduler cette affirmation un peu
cocorico la première modulation c'est
que nous restons très en de ça de nos
partenaires les chiffres du chômage sont
mauvais en France quand on se compare à
l'étranger je crois que dans l'Union
européenne on est 23e ou 24e sur sur
l'ensemble des pays de l'Union
européenne donc les chiffres sont
formellement bons si on les compare au
chiffres deil y a quelques années reste
mauvais quand on se compare au aux
autres le deuxième point c'est qu'une
part très importante de l'amélioration
des chiffres du chômage s'explique par
les sorts de l'apprentissage euh les
études montrent que 2 tiers en fait de
l'amélioration des chiffres totaux du
chômage sont expliqués par le recours
plus important à l'apprentissage et donc
ces deux éléments doivent peut-être
moduler le discours très très très
victorieux que que qu'on entend par-ci
et par là sur les éléments budgétaires
qui nous sont présentés et qui font que
euh nous sommes républi en l'état très
réservé sur l'adoption de cette mission
premièrement la question du France
compéten France compétence qui a été
très
critiqué sur sur son mode de
fonctionnement sur son efficacité dès
2000 dès 2020 l'inspection générale des
finances alertaé à ce sujet une sorte de
puissant fond et on voit que d'année en
année l'État est amené à apporter des
milliards d'euros pour compenser un trou
qui n'en finit pas de se creuser et donc
nous sommes très réservés sur la
question de France
compétence plus 2,5 milliards par
rapport à l'année dernière euh et pour
la seule année 2022 France compétence
c'est enregistré un déficit de 1
milliard et demi d'euros malgré déjà les
4 milliards de rallonge accordé par
l'État et c'est sans compter sans le
plan de relance qui avait déjà aussi
financé France compét à hauteur de 750
millions déjà assorti d'une obligation
pour le conseil d'administration de
voter des mesures permettant d'atteindre
l'équilibre en 2022 donc on voit qu'on y
est pas et une des questions qu'on a
envie de vous poser c'est qu'est-ce qui
est prévu pour enfin arriver à
l'équilibre
deuxième très gros bémol c'est la
question du compte personnel de
formation qui a été un succès compte
personnel de formation je pense c'est un
élément qui qu'il faut avoir en tête
depuis quelques années les choses se
sont vraiment améliorées en particulier
avec un nettoyage de tous ces gens qui
proposaient des formations qui qui
n'étaient pas qualifiantes en tout cas
qui n'était pas
performante et ça ça marche plutôt bien
or on entend dire que désormais sont
évoqué des pistes de mise en place d'un
ticket modérateur de l'ordre de 30 %
pour l'utilisation du compte personnel
de formation et si je comprends bien on
demanderait à des Français ou des
françaises qui bénéficient qui veulent
bénéficier de leur compte personnel de
formation qui veulent être formé bah de
contribuer à 30 % de la dépense liée à
cette formation quand on sait qu'une
formation moyenne c'est 2000 € et bien
on imagine qu'on va demander à des gens
qui ont par définition des revenus qui
sont très faibles des sommes
considérable de l'ordre de 800 € et nous
voudrions qu'il y ait des engagements à
ce sujet enfin 3ème point je terminerai
là-dessus ça a été évoqué par mes
collègue cette question de la ponction
totalement injuste sur les recettes de
l'unedi car on entend qu'il faut de
l'argent pour France travail mais
l'Unedic c'est un organisme paritaire
qui gère l'assurance chômage qui est à
l'équilibre et on dit que parce qu'il
est à l'équilibre on va le ponctionner
mais enfin d'abord c'est oublié que la
priorité lunedque c'est de remplir sa
mission et la deuxème priorité de
l'Unedic c'est que ledic a des un
endettement qui est très important et
donc les excédents deunedic que l'on
chaque année doivent d'abord servir à
purer l'UNIC voilà Monsieur le Ministre
pourquoi les républicains soutiendront
pas l'adoption de cette mission merci
pour le groupe modem démocrate et
indépendant Monsieur Laurent Leclerc
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre monsieur le rapporteur pour
ma première prise de parole à
l'Assemblée nationale comme député de
rloir je suis heureux de vous interroger
sur l'effort de l'État en faveur du
plein emploi je sais cet enjeu également
cher à Philippe Vigier nommé ministre
des outremèes dont j'ai l'honneur de
poursuivre le mandat parlementaire je
tâcherai d'inscrire mes pas dans les
siens en particulier au sein de cette
commission dont j'ai pe j'ai pu mesurer
la qualité mais également l'intensité
des débats en cours des dernières
semaines j'en profite pour vous
remercier mes chers collègues de votre
excellent
accueil monsieur le ministre en
complément de la hausse des crédits
budgétaires de la mission travail et
emploi que vous nous avez présenté ma
question portera sur
l'apprentissage comme le démontre la
très forte insertion professionnelle des
jeunes passés par l'apprentissage il
s'agit d'une voie privilégiée vers
l'emploi 70 % d'entre eux étaient en
effet en emploi dans les 6 mois suivant
leur
diplôme aujourd'hui plus de 5 ans après
la promulgation de la loi pour la
liberté de choisir son avenir profession
nous constatons d'excellents résultats
en la matière avec 837000 apprentis par
an en
2022 pour mémoire je vous rappelle que
nous étions bloqués à moins de 300000
jusqu'à 2017 et que nous regardions avec
envie les importantes cortte d'apprentis
de nos voisins
allemands la simplification et
l'augmentation des des aides a
indéiablement contribué à ces bons
chiffres démontrant l'importance d'une
action politique volontaire pour aider
les jeunes à s'in sur le marché du
travail le groupe démocrate se félicite
donc des près de 4 milliards d'euros de
la mission travail et emploi consacré à
l'embraoche des apprentis pour
2024 à présent monsieur le ministre
quelles sont les prochaines étapes pour
parvenir à l' l'objectif d'un million de
nouveaux apprentis par an comment se
concentrer sur les jeunes pour lesquels
l'apprentissage représente la plus forte
valeur ajoutée je pense notamment au
diplômés d'un bac technologique ou
encore au 10000 jeunes en situation de
handicap par ailleurs dans le cadre du
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour
2024 notre groupe apporté un amendement
relatif au recouvrement des
contributions additionnelles à la
formation
professionnelle cet amendement prévoyait
de maintenir pour les branches
professionnelles qui le souhaitent la
ité de confier aux URSAF son
recouvrement tant pour des raisons de
simplicité que d'efficacité ou encore de
savoir-faire le réseau des URSAF nous
apparaît comme le meilleur outil de
recouvrement possible notamment auprès
des petites
entreprise par conséquent pouvez-nous
nous présenter monsieur le ministre
votre position sur le sujet et
pourrionsnous maintenir la possibilité
pour les URSAF de collecter les
contributions conventionnelles
supplémentaires notamment auprès des
branches professionnelles volontaires je
vous en
remercie merci pour le groupe socialiste
et apparenté monsieur Arthur de
laaporte pardon merci monsieur le
Président c'est forcément singulier
d'auditionner un ministre merci Monsieur
le Ministre d'être présent néanmoins sur
des crédits dont nous
débattrons peut-être la semaine
prochaine alors que nous savons pertin
qu'ils seront décidés aux 57 rue de
varen sans que les représentants élus
n'ent leur mot à dire sur les politiques
publique de l'emploi alors en l'attente
d'un nm 493 on fait semblant on se
mobilise comme si ce gouvernement ou
comme si la majorité allait enfin
construire le budget de la France avec
les oppositions finalement on a un peu
l'impression d'être dans un mauvais Vau
ville une mauvaise comédie un mauvais
sketch bref chaque groupe politique
donne son avis sur un budget certain
hausse mais qui traduit surtout une
idéologie nous dirons néolibérale vous
le contesterez le recul de l'ompagnement
des plus précaires le renforcement
massif des aides aux employeurs
d'apprentis on pourrait vous rétorquer
qu'il y a l'art et la manière l'art
d'enchaîner les 493 à rebours de vos
promesses de légiférer autrement en
prenant en compte le résultat des ur ça
vous maîtrisez plutôt bien en revanche
la manière c'est peut-être peut mieux
faire parce qu'on y est pas encore
refuser le débat en séance publique en
activant vos 493 en faisant comme si ce
geste était devenu anodin alors même que
nous traversons une grave crise
démocratique refuser d'attendre la fin
des débats comme si le Parlement ne
méritait même pas de débattre de
proposer de construire vous savez que
les amendements que nous pourrons
adopter ici en commission comme on a pu
le faire en commission des affaires des
finances hier soir n'auront pas
d'incidence sur le texte final alors oui
le vote ne compte pas tant que ça
finalement d'autres dans notutre temps
cumulé pourtant de conditions préalables
c'était la manière je pense notamment à
Michel Rocard monsieur le ministre que
vous avez connu qui faisait un 493 après
le débat et qui retenait l'ensemble des
amendements qui avaient été adoptés
alors inspirez-vous même si vous faites
des 493 à minima de Michel
Rocard je vais néanmoins tenter de
prendre un mauvais second rôle dans
cette comédie tragédie ce budget en
hausse n'est qu'une fois de plus un
trompelœil un trompleœil qui s'inscrit
dans un contexte exceptionnel réforme de
l'assurance chômage des retraite dur SAA
votre budget ne pouvait qu'être
insincère alors Monsieur le Ministre
comment allez-vous faire tourner votre
machine France travail avec seulement 70
millions supplémentaires selon nos
calculs il faudrait 10 milliards pour
assouvir votre accord des droites à
savoir les 15 heures d'activité monsieur
le ministre pensez-vous aux agens de Pô
emploi qui ne pourront pas suivre ce
rythme infernal que vous leur imposez
vos recrutements sont évidemment
insuffisants puis-je pour vous inciter
peut-être à m'écouter et me répondre
vous demander ce que vous allez faire
combien de recrutement à l'agence
d'anoné ou à celle de Tournon et puis ce
budget c'est encore une fois Monsieur le
Ministre j'espère que vous m'écouterez
mais encore une fois la sens totale de
prise en compte des inégalités femmes
hommes de prise en compte du genre dans
le budget de l'amélioration des
conditions de travail et de rémunération
des femmes plutôt que abreuver les
entreprises etincitonner à être plus
juste enfin et je vais utiliser la
dernière minute qui me reste monsieur le
ministre pour tenter de vous
interroger un peu plus sincèrement que
tout à l'heure en hémicycle sur
territoire zéro chômeur longue durée
j'espère que vous serez sensible au vote
qui a été celui de la commission des
finances hier et qui sera je l'espère
celui de notre commission lorsque nous
l'examinerons qui a donné plus de budget
à territoire zéro chômeur longue durée
tout à l'heure vous avez émis deux
contevérités la première c'est que vous
dites qu'il n'y a pas de visibilité sur
les trajectoires d'embauche partager
pourtant elles sont validées par vos
services quand il y a un nouveau
territoire expérimentateur il y a une
trajectoire d'embauche et vous l'avez
donc connu la deuxième contrev monsieur
le ministre c'est que vous dites que
territoire zéro chôur et j'espère que
vous m'écoutez que vous me répondrez a
toujours sous-consommé son budget ce
n'est pas vrai quand il y a eu des
conventions d'objectif et de moyens vous
avez fixé un budget il a toujours été
rempli sauf lors du covid donc il n'y a
jamais de consommation c'est de
sous-consommation c'est un c'est une
contevérité de le
dire pour le groupe horizon et apparenté
la parole est à Monsieur François
gerigon merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
nous nous apprêtons à discuter et voter
les crédits alloués à la mission travail
et emploi pour l'exercice 2024 dont le
montant s'élève à 22,8 milliards d'euros
en autorisation d'engagement et 22,5
milliards d'euros en crédit de paiement
reflétant une augmentation notable de
plus de 12 % et 8 % respectivement par
rapport à 2023 cette Haus symbolise
l'engagement résolu du gouvernement en
faveur de
l'employabilité notamment des publics
les plus éloignés de l'emploi tels que
les jeunes les demandeurs d'emploi et
les personnes en situation de
handicap nous accueillons avec
enthousiasme l'effort continu à travers
des initiatives telles que le contrat
d'engagement jeune et l'insertion par
l'activité économique ainsi que la mise
en œuvre du projet de loi pour le plein
emploi cela marque un pas significatif
vers l'objectif capital du plein emploi
qui nous le savons est plus que jamais
d'actualité lorsque nous observons les
chiffres du chômage qui était au 2e
trimestre un niveau le plus bas depuis
40 ans ainsi que l'utau d'emploi des 15
64 ans au niveau le plus élevé jamais
enregistré avec
68,6 %. l'accent mis sur la formation et
l'amélioration des compétences des
demandeurs d'emploi et des actifs est un
pilier central de cette mission en
transition vers la mise en place de
France travail le groupe Horizon est
apparenté se joint pleinement à cette
démarche et votera en faveur de cette
mission
budgétaire cependant monsieur le
ministre j'aimerais attirer votre
attention sur une dimension cruciale du
marché du travail l'emploi des seigneurs
qui peuvent rapidement se retrouver
éloignés du marché du travail une
situation qui nécessite une réflexion
approfondies et des mesures adéquates
leur employabilité n'est pas seulement
une question de justice sociale mais
aussi un impératif économique le taux
d'emploi des seigneurs en France se
situe à 57 % ce qui malgré une
augmentation continue reste bien
inférieure à la moyenne européenne de 62
% et bien en dessous des taux observés
en Suède 77 % et en Allemagne 73 %.
d'après certaines analyses atteindre le
taux d'emploi des seigneurs français sur
celui de l'Allemagne pourrait augmenter
notre PIB de 8 % d'ici 2040 représentant
un gain de 200 milliards d'euros et
s'accompagner d'une hausse conséquente
des recettes publiques d aux cotisations
supplémentaires engendré par plus de
quantité de
travail nombreuses propositions méritent
une forte considér
comme le déplafonnement du compte
personnel de formation pour les salariés
seurs cela leur permettrait s'il le
souhaite de bénéficier de formation
approfondie facilitant ainsi une
réorientation professionnelle
qualifiante beaucoup expriment une
volonté de continuer à travailler mais
sous des modalités
différentes je souhaite également que
vous puissiez monsieur le ministre
impulser une discussion sur la création
d'un congé dédié au salariés sur le
point d' la catégorie je peux m'exprimer
ainsi des salariers
seigneurs ce temps de pause serait une
opportunité pour ces salariés d'engager
une réflexion approfondie sur la
trajectoire de leur future année
professionnelle tout en bénéficiant d'un
accompagnement adapté pour le
faire monsieur le ministre quelle
initiative supplémentaire le
gouvernement envisage-t-il pour garantir
une meilleure inclusion des seigneurs
sur le marché du travail quels sont les
délais que le gouvernement s'est fixé
pour la conférence char de travailler à
un consensus de propositions je vous
remercie merci pour le groupe écologiste
madame Sandrine Rousseau monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Rapporteur
monsieur le ministre chers collègues
étrange calendrier que ce projet de loi
de finance puisque nous votons nous
votions hier les crédits de la mission
travail emploi en commission des
finances pour laquelle nous auditionnons
seulement le ministre ce jour et qu'en
plus cela va se poursuivre sans peu de
doute sur un 493 la mission travail
emploi porte les crédits permettant la
mise en œuvre des politiques publiques
pour l'emploi la formation
professionnelle et le travail cette
mission est évidemment absolument
fondamentale quand on regarde le triste
tableau de la réalité du travail dans
notre pays 9 millions de personnes en
précarité avec moins de 1100 € par mois
38 % des chômeurs vivant sous le seuil
de pauvreté
390000 personnes sorties des chiffres du
chômage au 1emier trimestre 2023 17 %
des jeunes au RSA les personnes seules
avec une personne à charge constitue 32
% de l'ensemble des allocataires du RSA
évidemment il s'agit évidemment de
majoritairement de maère de famille
monoparentale un jeune actif sur 5 âgé
de 20 à 24 ans sans emploi un chiffre
qui a été multiplié par 2 sur 40 ans 37
% des actifs occupés français disaient
que leur travail était insoutenable
derrière ces chiffres sur 4 ans pardon
derrière ces chiffres la multiplication
des travailleurs pauvres du chômage de
longue durée de la difficulté d'accès à
un an emploi pour les jeunes des
problématiques qui ne trouvent pas grâce
aux yeux du gouvernement obnubilé par sa
baisse du chômage mais de quelle baisse
du chômage parle- ton selon la Darès
concernant les chiffres du chômage la
diminution des catégories A entre le 4e
trimestre 2022 et le 1er trimestre 2023
se fait en parallèle d'une augmentation
des catégories B et C sur la même
période le plein emploi n'existe pas en
revanche le malemploi lo oui existe et
celui-ci se traduit par une
précarisation croissante du travail
marquée par l'explosion des contrats
courts et une stagnation des salaires
mais le gouvernement a une solution
attention France travail France travail
qui organise une inscription massive des
personnes éloignées de l'emploi ou en
difficulté d'insertion sociale au
travail France travail qui derrière la
promesse d'un service public de l'emploi
totalement renouvelé accompagnant les
usagers au plus proche de leur besoin
cache en réalité la volonté de piloter
le marché du travail pour faire
coïncider à marche forcée l'offre et la
demande quel que soit l'offre et quelle
que soit la demande pendant
l'intégralité de l'examen de ce texte
nous avons posé une question quels
moyens seront mis sur la table pour
déployer la mise en place de
l'accompagnement intensif que vous
chérissez tant nous y sommes + 300 ETP
en 2024 un financement via une ponction
de l'unéic et le maintien de la
subvention pour charge de service public
de 1 25 milliards d'euros versé par
l'État dont une affectation de 300
millions d'euros dédié à
l'accompagnement des demandeurs d'emploi
une enveloppe de 70 millions de 170
millions d'euros ouverte au titre de la
contractualisation avec les conseils
départementaux pour le déploiement des
expérimentation visant à intensifier
l'accompagnement des bénéficiaires du
RSA bilan le programme semble largement
en dà des besoins nécessaires d'abord
selon votre gouvernement cette réforme
coûte déjà entre 2 et 2,3 et 2, 7
milliards d'euros où sont-ils ensuite en
France le ratio est d'un conseiller pour
98 inscrits à l'heure actuelle il
faudrait 40000 conseillers
supplémentaires pour accompagner
correctement 2 millions d'allocatair où
sont les créations de postes s'agissant
de l'Unedic enfin pourquoi s'endetter à
la ponctionner sachant que cette
dernière est déjà largement endettée et
sera obligé d'emprunter à court terme
sur les marchés pour honorer ses
échéances ce qui devrait lui coûter près
de 800 millions d'euros sur 4 ans
monsieur le ministre pour résumer où
sont les milliards nécessaires ils sont
absents les masques tombent le manque de
moyens met en lumière la réalité de
l'intention de la réforme de de
l'assurance chômage toujours plus de
contrainte toujours plus de pression
toujours moins d'accompagnement et de
solidarité merci pour le groupe Gauche
démocrate et républicaine monsieur
Yannick Mony merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre la présentation
stratégique de la mission travail et
emploi affiche de nouveau votre ambition
du plein emploi France travail est au
cœur de ce budget depuis la fin de l'été
vous soutenez votre stratégie en argant
d'une baisse sans précédent les chiffres
du chômage en mai dernier vous annonciez
ainsi triomphalement ouvrez les
guillemets le taux de chauvage au
premier trimestre 2023 s'établit à 7,1 %
son plus bas niveau depuis
1982 sans même revenir sur les
différences entre la méthode de comptage
du BIT et celle de Pôle emploi je vais
simplement rappeler des chiffres qui
contredisent largement votre optimisme
selon le BIT il y a 2,2 millions de
chômeurs selon pô emploi il y en a 5,39
millions toute catégorie confondu dont 3
millions en catégorie A l'OFCE a très
récemment alerté sur une inversion de la
courbe du chômage en France qu'elle
prévoit dans la fourchette basse à 7,4 %
fin 2023 et 7,9 % fin 2024 les derniers
chiffres publiés par la Dares pour le 3e
trimestre confirment l'étude de l'OFCE
taux de chômage à 7,3 % hausse de 0,6 %
en catégorie A et hausse encore des
emplois précaires il faut également
ajouter les effets de votre réforme des
retraites qui selon l'OFCE va dans les
deux premières années générer 177000
actifs supplémentaires sur le marché du
travail au lieu d'être en retêre face à
ces données objectives n'y a-t-il pas la
nécessité de revoir votre stratégie
global en matière d'emploi en matière de
budget pourriez-vous dire clairement
comment vous comptez financer France
travail quel moyen pour la
transformation de plan emploi en France
travail avec l'ensemble des nouvelles
missions qui lui seront dévolues et qui
ne sont plus axés sur l'orientation et
l'accpagnement des demandeurs d'emploi
lesquels n'en sont d'ailleurs plus
vraiment 300 nouvelles embauches certes
mais quel moyen supplémentairire pour la
transformation structurelle de Pôle
emploi la mise en place du réseau la
formation des agents serait-ce un budget
constant avez-vous encore la mauvaise
intention de piller les ressources de
l'Unedic pour trouver 2 à 2,7 milliards
d'euros sur les 3 ans qui viennent le
chômage des moins de 25 ans était encore
de plus de 16 % en juillet dernier et ne
se réduit pas 17 % des jeunes sont ORSA
pourtant dans ce cadre ce budget fait le
choix de baisser les crédits de paiement
d'mission locales pour 2024 c'est
632,7 million contre 633 millions en
2023 alors qu'elles auront comme en 2023
la tâche à signé de suivre 200000 jeunes
en CEJ comme nous le redoutions
escontez-vous un suivi plus important
par France travail au détriment des
missions locales vous misez par ailleurs
beaucoup et toujours plus sur
l'alternance tout en déployant une
réforme des lycées professionnels qui
négl ige l'accès à l'enseignement
général et donc réduit la possibilité de
changement professionnel pour rappel un
salarié tout au long de sa carrière
professionnel changera 6 à 7 fois
d'emploi ainsi si les budgets alloués au
dispositif de soutien au déploiement de
l'apprentissage baissent de 90 % ce sont
les aides aux employeurs d'apprentis qui
connaissent une forte croissance plus
743 % en CP qui passe de 419 millions en
2023 à 3,5 milliards en 2024 en vue
d'atre 1 million en vue d'atteindre
pardon million d'apprentis par
an les députés du groupe Renaissance ont
va adopter en commission des finances
hier un amendement visant à réguler les
aides à l'apprentissage en fonction du
diplôme du niveau de diplôme visé par
l'apprenti ainsi les entreprises de plus
de 250 salariés l'aide unique à
l'embauche d'un apprenti serait supprimé
lorsque l'apprenti prépare un diplôme
supérieur à un bac + 2 cet amendement
nous semble créer une dissociation entre
le désir d'être apprenti et celui de
faire des études supérieures et
participer à fermer les voie de
progression salariale par les études
supérieurs via l'apprentissage ma
dernière question soutenez-vous cette
disposition je vous
remercie merci et pour le groupe liberté
indépendant autre maire et territoire la
parole est à Monsieur Laurent panifous
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues permettez-moi de
commencer mon propos en relativisant la
hausse des crédits de la mission travail
et emploi compte tenu de l'ambition même
du gouvernement en matière de plein
emploi je ne je ne reviendrai pas sur
les désaccords de notre groupe sur vos
réformes de l'assurance chômage et des
retraites mais je m'interroge de ne pas
constater dans ce budget les impacts que
celles-ci auront assurément sur le
marché du travail un seul exemple la
baisse de la dotation en direction du
financement des allocations pour les
personnes en fin de droit au chômage
alors que pour la seule réforme des
retraites les premières estimations
anticipent une augmentation du nombre
d'allocataires de minimas sociaux de
60000 personnes d'autres éléments nous
questionnent vous affichez votre volonté
d'améliorer l'accompagnement des
demandeurs d'emploi dans le cadre du
projet de loi pour le plein emploi mais
vous ne vous donnez pas réellement les
moyens de le faire dans ce budget la
subvention pour charge de service
publics àemploi est stable après
plusieurs années de baisse elle reste
toutefois en dessa de son niveau de 2017
et vous ne prévoyez que 300 équivalent
temp plein supplémentaires pour
l'opérateur alors que le nombre de
conseillers est déjà aujourd'hui
insuffisant idem du côté desmissions
locales dont les crédits sont stables
alors que l'on pourrait s'attendre à une
augmentation du nom nombre de jeunes
suivis en d'autres termes notre groupe
s'interroge sur les moyens mis en œuvre
pour remplir l'objectif de plein emploi
que vous fixez et le projet France
travail l'accompagnement des demandeurs
d'emploi devait être devrait être une
priorité nous ne la voyons pas dans ce
budget nous voyant en revanche que
l'Unedic qui malgré une amélioration
budgétaire souffre toujours d'une dette
élevée sera elle mise à contribution
pour financer la réforme concernant les
dispositifs d'insertion pour les plus
éloignés de l'emploi nous avons deux
points de préoccupation importants le
premier concerne les crédits pour
l'expérimentation territoire zéro
chômeur de longue durée les financements
doivent être honorés les engagements
doivent être tenus vous ne pouvez pas
anticiper les résultats des évaluations
et décider unilatéralement d'une moindre
participation à une expérimentation que
vous avez vous-même choisi d'étendre la
seconde concerne les travailleurs
handicapés le rapprochement des CAP
EMPLOI et de Pôle emploi au sein de
France travail tout comme les droits
nouveaux accordé aux bénéficiaires des
zates dans le projet de loi plein emploi
justifierait une augmentation adaptée
des moyens comment les concrétisez-vous
je terminerai enfin sur notre dernière
inquiétude qui concerne les jeunes et
notamment la formation d'abord pour dire
que le premier bilan du contrat
d'engagement jeune est mitigé en terme
d'heure d'accompagnement notamment et
surtout le dispositif apparaît encore
sous-calibré comparé au nombre de
potentiels bénéficiaires enfin
s'agissant de l'apprentissage que notre
re groupe soutien bien sûr nous nous
interrogeons comme d'autres sur un
éventuel effet d'ben pour certaines
entreprises envisagez-vous un meilleur
ciblage des aides notamment en direction
des moins diplômés la question est
d'autant plus importante que la
situation financière de France
compétence est toujours difficile ce qui
interroge sur sa capacité à pérenniser
les dispositifs de formation voilà
Monsieur le Ministre autant d'éléments
qui nous amènent à relativiser les
hausses de crédit de cette mission et
sur la politique de la emploi de manière
générale je vous
remercie merci chers collègues monsieur
le ministre jeose d'apporter les
premiers élément de
répones merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président sur les différents points
notamment les points évoqués par
Monsieur le le rapporteur d'abord une
réponse sur la forme pour vous dire
Monsieur le rapporteur je suis désolé du
faible taux de réponse aux questions
parlementaires constatées au 10 octobre
euh j'ai moi-même été parlementaire et
je n'appréciis pas être confronté à ce
niveau-là et cela fait partie des
instructions que j'ai donné et des
questions que j'ai pu poser j'ai dis
question pour ne pas dire colère que
j'ai pu avoir à la lecture de de ces
chiffresl et il faut que nous fassions
mieux et nous ferons mieux sur les
moyens consacrés d'abord à la mise en
place de France travail cel a été évoqué
par plusieurs députés la montée en
puissance de France travail est par par
définition et c'est écrit dans la loi
une monté en puissance progressive en
2024 nous devons avoir en tête que la
loi relative au plein emploi ne sera pas
encore en application de manière
générale la généralisation est prévue
pour le 1er janvier 2025 5 et donc sur
2024 nous avons essentiellement deux
choses à à accompagner à financer
d'abord la monté en puissance des
expérimentation nous avons 18
départements qui expérimentent 18
départements qui expérimentent dont
certains veulent élargir le territoire
d'expérimentation et nous avons d'autres
départements qui souhaitent intégrer
cette expérimentation les 170 millions
consacrés à la contractualisation avec
les département permettront
d'accompagner cette monté en puissance
de l'expérimentation et permettront
aussi de financer la transition du
modèle actuel vers le modèle France
travail je pense notamment à la
contractualisation sur la méthode et les
systèmes d'information je pense aussi à
la contractualisation pour transformer
le modèle de garantie d'activité
départementale en modèle France travail
c'est l'objet des 170 millions de
contractualisation avec les départements
par ailleurs l'opérateur poemploi va
bénéficier de 300 équivalent temp plein
supplémentair dans le casre d'une
expérimentation qui est pas ressence
progressive aujourd'hui nous avons 4000
bénéficiaires du RSA qui sont sur des
territoires d'expérimentation et donc la
montée en puissance nous permettra de
l'accompagner et et je précise que d'ici
2027 nous serons sur un montant
d'augmentation des moyens dont dispose
France travail pour l'emploi aujourd'hui
France travail à partir du 1er janvier
d'un milliard d'euros par an par rapport
à aujourd'hui ce qui nous permettra très
largement d'atteindre les les objectifs
qui sont ainsi ainsi fixés sur les
questions relatives au au contrat aidés
et au au très grand écart que vous avez
souligné entre 450000 contrats aidés il
y a presque une dizaine d'années et
90000 aujourd'hui d'abord je pense que
cet écart doit être relativisé par le
fait que lorsqu'il y avait 450000
employés nous étions dans une période de
chômage de masse à la sortie d'une crise
financière et par ailleurs il n'existait
pas de modèle spécifiquees
d'accompagnement des jeunes sans emploi
d' information je pense au 300000 contre
engagement jeunes qui ont é signé en
2023 au 300000 que nous prévoyons pour
2024 n nous considérons que lorsque
l'emploi s'améliore il est normal que
les emplois aidés soient nombreux et
j'ai donné instruction aux différents
préfets de concentrer la mise en œuvre
de ces contrats aidés sur les publics
les plus éloignés notamment les
allocataires du RSA les demandeurs
d'emploi en situation d' handicap ceux
qui ont le niveau de formation le le
moins élevé pour retrouver pleinement la
dimension d'insertion des des contrats
aidés je vous confirme monsieur le
rapporteur que l'augmentation des moyens
consacrés au dialogue social est
essentiellement lié à l'organisation du
scrutin spécifique pour les TPE et aux
règles de de représent de
représentativité que vous avez évoqué je
voudrais vous dire aussi monsieur le
rapporteur sur les deux sujets
thématiques que vous avez apportés
d'abord concernant la question du sport
que pour ce qui concerne le référentiel
commande de formation pour le sport et
la qualification dans le domaine du
sport c'est c'est un chantier qui est
piloté directement par le le ministère
thématique en charge c'est c'estàd le
ministère du sport des sports pardon que
nous accompagnons nous avons toujours
cet objectif que les prochaines semaines
nous permettent la publication de ce
référentiel commun qui sera bien utile
par ailleurs n nous avons inscrit des
crédits relatifs à à l'accompagnement de
la VAE dans le cadre des crédits
éligibles au au au pactes régionaux
d'investissement dans les compétences
c'est une demande portée par nombre de
de représentants de la RF ce qui
permettra d'accompagner la montant
puissance de la VAE en particulier pour
les les les acteurs de l'insertion par
par et et pour le sport nous le faisons
dans le cadre de la feuille de route que
que vous avez rappelé qui fixe cet
objectif ambitieux de 100000 emplois
supplémentaires dans le monde du sport
et d'e multiplication par 5 de de
l'entrée en insertion et les premiers
résultats que nous avons sont positifs
puisque indépendamment des crédits
consacrés à cette question par le
ministère du sport et je pense notamment
au crédits annoncé pour la
professionnalisation des associations
lors du dernier comité interministériel
de la ville ce sont 20000 millions
d'euros qui sont consacrés aux actions
d'insertion par et pour le sport dans le
cadre du pic 100 % inclusion avec 5000
bénéficiaires en quartier politique de
la ville principalement autour des
actions de repérage et de remobilisation
de valorisation des compétences et avec
des taux de sortie positif qui sont
intéressants tant vers l'emploi durable
ou l'emploi à durée déterminée pour 52 %
ou encore presque 15 % en formation
est-ce que nous allons évaluer oui tout
toutes les actions du pic 100 %
inclusion ont vocation à être évalué
avant d'être pérénisé comment est-ce que
nous allons p is grâce à l'article 6 de
de la loi pour le plein emploi qui
reconnaît aux associations et et aux
personnes morales de droit privé
associations fondations parfois
entreprise à à but entreprise pardon
sociale à d'utilité solidaire la
possibilité d'être reconnu comme des
acteurs du du marché de l'emploi et du
service public de l'emploi et donc
d'être conventionné dans le cadre de
convention pluriannuelle vous avez
évoqué monsieur le rapporteur et et vous
n'avez pas été le seul l'expérimentation
territoire zéro chemur de longue duré je
voudrais apporter un certain nombre de
de précisions en essayant de couvrir
chacune des questions qui a été abordé
je l'ai dit tout à l'heure lors des
questions au gouvernement en en 2017
c'est un budget de 15 millions d'euros
qui est inscrit dans la loi de finances
de l'État pour accompagner territoire zé
chemurs de longue durée en 2023 ce sont
44,9 millions d'euros et nous avons
prévu d'inscrire 69 millions d'euros
j'ai dit tout à l'heure et je le
maintiens qu'il y a eu systématiquement
une sous-consommation des crédits de
l'État alloué à l'expérimentation
territoire zé chemur de longue durée en
2017 14900000 € inscrits 400002
consommés en 2018 18 mil00ons inscrits 9
mil00li00 consommés en 2019 22004
inscrits 9008 consommés en 2020 285
inscrits 11,1 million consommés en 2021
28,6 million inscrits 12 m009 consommés
en 2022 32,8 millions inscrits 25li4
consommés à date sur les 44, 9 million
d'euros inscrits pour le PLF 2023 ce
sont moins de 31 millions d'euros qui
ont été mobilisés il a été évoqué la
perspective de l'année 2024 69 millions
d'euros sont inscrits cela nous paraît
suffisant au vu de ce taux de
consommation des crédits de l'État
inscrit dans la loi de finances il
viennent s'ajouter à cela évidemment la
participation des départements et des
intercommunalités j'ai pris l'engagement
de déposer les décrets nécessaires au
Conseil d'État pour pouvoir labelliser
25 territoires en plus des prévu par la
loi et effectivement nous avons ramené
le taux de prise en charge de l'État et
uniquement d'état de 102 à 95 %
c'est-à-dire le niveau de 2019 il faut
savoir que la loi les deux lois qui ont
été adoptées concernant territoire zé
chur ont prévu un plancher
d'intervention de l'État à 53 % du
montant du SMIC nous sommes aujourd'hui
à 95 %. j'ai indiqué et et j'aurais
l'occasion de le dire directement à
Monsieur Galois leur c'est c'est 53 %
dans la loi le plancher d'intervention
c'est écrit dans la loi lo c'est comme
ça vous n'étiez pas là pour la voter je
l'ai voté et et c'est à 53 %. sur la la
suite j'ai dit à Monsieur Galois n avons
j'ai mon cabinet a dit à Monsieur
Gallois et je lui dirai directement
jeudi que nous sommes prêts à prendre
l'engagement d'apporter 10 millions
d'euros en gestion en 2024 si les 69
millions d'euros n'étaient pas
suffisants ce dont je peux douter
légitimement au niveau au vu des taux de
de consommation des exercices précédent
il a été évoqué je crois par par
Monsieur Juvin et par vous-même monsieur
le rapporteur
la nécessité d'une subvention
d'équilibre euh nous avons dit à
l'association que pour l'accompagner
dans ces questions de trésorerie pour
l'année 2023 nous étions prêts à lui
attribuer 1500000 € de trésorerie à date
l'association nous a indiqué n'avoir
besoin de mobiliser que 500000 € sur ces
1500000 €. est-ce que nous allons
évaluer oui et j'ai confié au professeur
Lory la présidence du comité
scientifique d'évaluation qui nous
rendra ses conclusions à l'été 2024 de
manière à ce que nous puissions que nous
puissions ainsi avancer
sur cette question là nous continuerons
à discuter mais dire que il y aurait une
baisse alors que nous sommes passés de
nous passons de 45 à 69 millions d'euros
me paraît étonnant surtout avec 10
millions que nous pouvons apporter en en
gestion sur les autres sujets qui ont
été évoqués je voudrais dire à Monsieur
leac que il y a deux sujets
principalement sur lesquels je souhaite
rebondir dans son intervention d'abord
la question du plan d'investissement
dans les compétences ça fait le lien
avec un certain nombre d'interventions
et et de demandes sur l'emploi des par
exemple le le plan d'investissement dans
les compétences aujourd'hui il existe et
il a été ouvert en 2018 il prévoit que
sont éligibles au financement les
formations dispensées au demandeurs
d'emploi ayant un niveau de
qualification inférieur au bac dans le
casadre du nouveau plan que nous
discutons avec les région nous avons
prévu d'apporter deux modifications
d'abord pour les demandeurs d'emploi de
moins de 26 ans nous ouvrons
l'éligibilité du financement des
formations jusqu'au demandeurs d'emploi
de moins de 26 ans etant une formation
inférieure à bac + 2 ce qui nous
permettra d'ouvrir l'accès à des
formations qualifiantes pour des jeunes
bâeliers mais qui ont pu connaître une
difficulté d'orientation en première ou
en deème année d'enseignement supérieur
ensuite nous supprimons purement et
simplement toute conditions de de
formation pour les demandeurs d'emploi
locataire du RSA pour les demandeurs
d'emploi en situation d'hicap et pour
les demandurs d'emploi de plus de 55 ans
c'est-à-dire les seniors considérant que
le fait d'être au chômage au-delà de 55
ans malgré une formation qui peuvent qui
pourrait être supérieur au bac ou à bac
+ 2 nécessite souvent une
requalification ou un reclassement pour
ce qui concerne l'anacte vous l'avez dit
Monsieur leac la loi santé au travail du
du 2 août 2021 a engagé sa
transformation avec la réunion de
l'anacte et des des des associations
régionales dans un réseau commun c'est
ce que nous nous accompagnons de la même
manière que nous accompagnons avec
l'augmentation de de la subvention les
les démarches notamment prévu dans le
cadre du Plan Santé au Travail numéro 4
sur l'intervention de l'ANAC dans la
prévention des addictions en milieu
professionnel ou encore en direction des
TPE et des PME puisque nous savons c'est
un terrain d'intervention sur lequel
nous devons aller plus rapidement nous
allons aussi faire en sorte de mobiliser
cette organisation sur la la prévention
de l'exposition aux facteurs les plus
dangereux notamment les facteurs
cancérigènes je pense à laamante ainsi
que à la prévention d'un certain nombre
d'autres maladies professionnelles qui
sont connu et qui peuvent être
dangereuses pour l'intervention de de
Monsieur ben sur la question des seniors
j'ai apporté un premier élément de
réponse avec l'éligibilité sans
conditions de diplôme au financement des
formations dans le cadre des des pics et
des pardon pour les acronymes je
voudrais ajouter mais ça fait le lien
avec d'autres interventions que nous
avons proposé au mois de juillet avec la
première ministre à l'ensemble des
parttenaires sociau représentatifs
d'ouvrir trois discussions autour trois
projets d'accords nationaux
interprofessionnels un sur le compte
pararentant universel un sur les
parcours les carrières les reconversions
avec toute cette logique de progression
de carrière et la simplification des
dispositifs de transition collective et
de transition professionnelle et enfin
un troisième sur l'emploi des seineurs
que nous ouvrons très largement à la
fois aux mesures qui ont fait l'objet
d'une censure par le Conseil
constitutionnel CDI senior index mais
aussi toutes les modalités possibles et
envisageables par les partenaires
sociaux et c'est donc des partenaires
sociaux que nous attendons que des
propositions soient faites pour l'emploi
des seniors accès et maintien dans
l'emploi formation reclassement 2e 3è
partie de carrière de manière à pouvoir
être le plus efficace possible et nous
avons pris l'engagement si un annie est
est conclu de le transposer dans la loi
et d' proposer une transposition
intégrale et complète au au prier
semestre 2024 le délai de négociation
est moi et je devrais envoyer le
document d'orientation dans les jours
qui viennent au aux partenaires sociaux
sur les les moyens dont dispose pôul
emploi dans le cadre de la mise en œuvre
de France travail je l'ai dit c'est à la
fois 300 millions d'euros
supplémentaires dès l'année prochaine
avec une chronique permettant d'avoir 1
milliard d'euros et et oui effectivement
cela passe à la fois par le maintien de
la subvention de l'État 1illard 250
millions d'euros et par une volonté de
notre part de la part du gouvernement
que l'Unedic puisse contribuer plus
fortement au financement de ces ses
politiques l'Unedic a connu un déficit
chronique d'un mliard 9 entre 2009 et
2019 100ard par an nous sommes à 4,4
milliards d'euros en 2022 d'excédent au
moins autant en 2023 et une chronique
qui dit qu'à 7 % de chômage ça sera 11
milliards d'excédents en 2026 qu'à 5 %
ce qui serait une très bonne nouvelle ça
sera 16 milliards d'euros et nous
considérons que affecter une partie de
ces excédents très importants en
financement des politiques d'emploi
c'est une forme de dépense active qui
cela permet le retour à l'emploi et ça
n'empêche pas un des dement d'au moins
40 % de la dette de de l'Unedic à
l'horizon de la fin du ququena ce qui
reste un objectif
ambitieux sur les les mesures de
régulation qui concernent le le CPF et
que et je précise que pour les les
moyens de l'emploi cela répond aussi à
la question de Monsieur cloué sur les
moyens de régulation du CPF que Monsieur
Juvin a évoqué d'abord vous confirmez
monsieur Juvin que les moyens les
mesures de régulation sont efficaces
puisque nous avons sécurisé les
connexions nous avons amélioré lesalif
iication que nous avons avec Carole
grandan ministre délégué auprès de de
moi pour les questions de formation
professionnelle d référencé un certain
nombre de formation mais aussi dé
référencer des organismes certificateurs
qui certifient tout et n'importe quoi si
vous me permettez cette expression et
cela nous permet de réaliser de
véritables économies avec dans les
semaines et les mois qui viennent un
travail complémentaire pour améliorer
encore la garantie de qualité et le
niveau de qualité des des formations
nous nous prévoyons effectivement je
l'ai dit dans mon propos liminaire une
participation d'un certain nombre
d'utilisateurs du CPF nous avons pris
deux engagements avec la première
ministre la première le premier
engagement c'est qu' un certain nombre
de ces utilisateurs en soit dispensés je
pense notamment lorsque l'utilisation se
fait dans le cadre d'un plan de
développement des compétences ou dans le
cadre d'un conseil en évolution
professionnel et par ailleurs vous avez
évoqué une participation à 30 % ça ne
sera absolument pas le cas nous sommes
plutôt sur l'idée d'une participation
forfaitaire sur des niveaux bien moins
importants qui pourrait se compter en
quelques dizaines d'euros mais c'est
renvoyé à une concertation que nous
aurons au printemps pas avant la fin du
1emer trimestre 2024 de manière à
pouvoir aussi l'articuler avec les les
éventuelles mesures de transition pour
les professionnel et Collectiv que les
partenaires sociaux pourraient inscrire
dans l'accord national
interprofessionnel que que j'ai évoqué
il y a il y a quelques instants France
compétence présente un déficit qui est
devenu chronique France compétence a été
créé et financé dans un cadre où nous
avions à peu près 300000 contrats
d'apprentissage par an et lorsque nous
sommes à 850000 ça crée ce besoin de
financement par l'État mais nous
considérons que c'est un investissement
utile au vu des taux d'insertion et de
la réussite de la politique de de
l'apprentissage monsieur Leclerc a
évoqué les questions d'apprentissage je
viens de les évoquer je peux simplement
ajouter que nous allons maintenir le
financement de des des préapprentissages
dans le cadre du plan d'investissement
dans les compétences c'est un moyen
utile pour pouvoir accompagner notamment
des des élèves en situation de
décrochage nous allons maintenir le
niveau d'accompagnement et je réponds
ainsi à la question de Monsieur Mony
aussi n nous maintiendrons en 2024 le
même niveau d'accompagnement a que celui
que nous connaissons je l'ai dit dans
mon propos liminaire et puis vous avez
posé une question plus particulière sur
le transfert du recouvrement des
contributions conventionnelles de
formation professionnelle et dialogue
social la loi venir pro 2018 a prévu le
transfert de la collecte de cette
contribution des OPCO au au URSAF cette
ce transfert est apparu comme trop
complexe pour beaucoup d'opco donc
l'article 8 du PLFSS supprime le
transfert mais je vous confirme que si
les branches qui le souhaitent que les
branches qui le souhaitent pourront sur
la base du volontariat décider de se
transfér aux urs nous travaillons
notamment avec l'UDP pour voir comment
organiser pratiquement cette mise en
œuvre volontaire et non pas obligatoire
du transfert pour les branches qui
jugeraiit que c'est plus simple donc la
réponse est positive à votre
interpellation ensuite monsieur deaporte
a évoqué le financement de Pemploi je
n'y reviens pas sur les questions
d'égalité professionnelle femme homme je
signe cependant que nous avons pris
l'engagement à la fois de de réviser
l'index égalité pro pour l'améliorer et
de transposer dans le même moment et
dans le même mouvement la directive sur
la transparence et l'égalité salariales
dont les décrets de transposition ont
été publiés aujourd'hui au Journal
officiel et nous allons transposer la
directive d'ici 18 mois alors que la
Commission européenne a laissé un délai
jusqu'à fin 2026 ce qui nous permet
d'aller plus vite je je ne reviens pas
Madame Rousseau sur les les éléments que
vous avez évoqué mais je vourais
simplement vous dire que les craintes
exprimé par quelques-uns au sujet du
coût de trésorerie pour l'unedi ne sont
pas fondé nous l'avons vu avec l'Unedic
et par ailleurs quand vous parlez de
précarisation de l'emploi je voudrais
souligner que dans tous les indicateurs
mais j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire dans
des questions au Gouvernement n nous
avons une part des CDI dans les emplois
dans les contrats signés de un mois et
plus d'un mois qui a dépassé les 52 % ce
qui n'était pas arrivé depuis plus de 10
ans donc on ne peut pas parler de de
précarisation enfin Monsieur Mony a
évoqué les moyens de France travail j'ai
j'ai répondu sur la prime apprentissage
aussi et pour ce qui concerne monsieur
panifou je vourais simplement dire
monsieur le député que les les missions
local garde 630 millions d'interventions
de crédit d'intervention ce qui est un
un reste un record historique à 1 ou 2
million d'euros près par rapport aux
années précédentes et et que nous avons
toujours le même objectif de 300000
contrats d'engagement d'engagement jeune
sachant que les jeunes concernés par
France travail au sein des missions
local ne sont que ceux des des CEJ ou
despéa puisque ce sont seulement les
jeunes dans une logique de recherche
d'emploi ou de formation qualifiante les
autres restent dans le système
d'accompagnement global que l'on a déjà
évoqué à plusieurs reprises pendant le
le débat sur le projet de loi voilà
monsieur le président merci monsieur le
ministre nous avons encore 10 questions
d'une minute à vous soumettre et donc je
cède la parole tout de suite à Monsieur
Fabien difilippo une
minute merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président je m'excuse à l'avance auprès
de Monsieur le Ministre un impératif de
transport m'obligera à suivre la suite
des débats à distance mais j'écouterai
attentivement je reprends vos mots
monsieur le ministre vous avez parlé
d'un objectif désormais atteignable du
plein emploi c'est les mots que vous
avez utilisé alors soit le plein emploi
en France est aujourd'hui à 7 % et dans
ce cas c'est dramatique soit certaines
évolutions récente vous ont échappé un
record de faill depuis 2016 annoncé pour
2023 une baisse des investissements et
des des entreprises une augmentation
même du du chômage qui repart très
légèrement à la hausse 01 % avec la la
destruction de de de plusieurs milliers
d'emplois l'OFCE la Banque de France
disent qu'en 2024 le chômage va remonter
sans doute vers les 8 % un tout petit
peu en dessous alors ma question est
très simple existe-t-il une hypothèse de
travail dans tout ce que vous avez
construit pour ces programmes ou ce ch
augmenterait vers les 8 % qui
permettrait de faire face à
l'accompagnement et à la prise en charge
que ça nécessite ù mon à nouveau toutous
sur la méthode Coué cher à Bruno Le
Maire merci Monsieur Nicolas turquis
oui merci monsieur le Président vous
avez été bien posé monsieur le ministre
dans dans vos réponses moi j'ai été
littéralement abassourdi parce qu'on a
entendu dans dans dans les interventions
qu'au moins on on dénote qu'il y a eu
une réduction massive du chômage dans le
dans le précédent quinquena je pense que
ça serait
ça serait pas trahir le l'opposition
partisane il faut il y a plein d'enjeux
à relever sur l'égalité sur l'égalité
femm hommes sur les emploi partiel subi
sur les bas salaires mais mais quand
même de de de de d'acter ce point je
pense que ça aurait été un minimum
d'honnêteté intellectuelle moi je
voudrais vous poser la question sur le
le plan de déploiement de de France
travail quand est-ce qu'URA lieu à votre
avis la mise en place du système
d'information commun comment vous le
voyez en terme de de département se
déployer jusqu'à quand est-ce que c'est
2025 2026 2027 il faut un un une
intensification de l'accompagnement ça
nécessite l'emploi de nombreuses
personnes et de nombreuses compétences
comment vous voyez le déploiement de
cette activité au-delà de 2024 merci
Monsieur Pierre
daréville merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre dans le projet de
loi de fin de gestion pour 2023 il est
indiqué que 2 milliards d'euros de
cotisation ne seront pas compensés via
la fraction de TVA l'unedant dégager des
excédents à cause de vos réformes de
réduction des droits ce qui n'éteint pas
d'ailleurs la dette ça finit par faire
beaucoup mais je voudrais vous
interroger peut-être meépondrez-vous
là-dessus mais je voudrais vous
interroger sur l'fpa son budget subit
une baisse dans un contexte
socio-économique qui lui est défavorable
la subvention d'État n'a pas varié
depuis 2018 ce qui questionne quant aux
injonctions qui sont faites à
l'opérateur public de revenir à la
stabilité financière pérenne en 2024
vous ne prenez pas en compte l'inflation
le triplement de la facture énergétique
représente 10 % du chiffre d'affaires
les dispositifs ne sont pas saclés le
plafond d'emploi empêche d'avancer et de
sécuriser or nous avons besoin d'unepa
puissante pour préparer au métier de
demain augmenter le niveau de
qualification il n' a quasiment pas été
question dans les grandes orientations
liées à fon travail quelle ambition
avez-vous pour
l'pa merci Madame Farida
Amrani merci monsieur le ministre le
budget qui nous est présenté est
insuffisant inadapté aux besoins réel de
la population tion vous le savez les
fonds qui qui seront alloués à Pôle
Emploi sont si faibles qu'il ne
permettront même pas les recrutements
nécessaire pour indiguer l'afflux des
des nouveaux
allocataires suite à la mise en place de
la plateforme France travail la
subvention de l'État à pôleemploi ne
cesse de diminuer ses baisses étaient de
200 millions d'euros l'année dernière et
de 80 millions cette année dans le PLF
qui nous est soumis est prévu la la
ponction des excédents de l'Unedic pour
financer France travail l'Unedic finance
aujourd'hui Pôle emploi à hauteur de 10
% de ses recettes le financement
supplémentaire de France travail serait
de 15 %. les assurés sont de moins en
moins indemnisés et ça et vos choix
politiques font peser sur eux un impôt
de financement des politiques de
l'emploi monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous nous garantir un financement
de notre service public de l'emploi à
hauteur des enjeux actuels merci madame
Rachel keké merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre du Travail je
profite pour de votre venue pour vous
exprimer ma colère concernant votre loi
plein emploi qui va donner naissance à
France travail pour rappel la semaine
dernière une réunion entre se députés et
7 sénateurs donc un accord entre le
gouvernement et
ont décidé de condamner à 15h
d'ebdomadeur de travail forcé près de 2
millions d'allocataires du RSA je suis
très en colère parce que en raison du
manque du cadre juridique de la loi vous
donnez l'occasion à des départements du
parti de rxioti d'interpréter
l'instrumentalisation euh et de
sanctionner les allocateurs du RSA en
coupant des aides vous venit de créer un
service public de l'emploi basé sur
l'inégalité territoriale les allocateurs
sont sanctionnés à la 4 en fonction de
la couleur politique du département de
sa richesse et de l'organisation terit
des services publics face à la misère
comment pouvez-vous laisser le risque de
l'arbitraire merci merci Madame
Marie-Charlotte Garin merci Monsieur le
Ministre moi je vais vous parler aussi
de l'expérimentation territoire zé
chômeurs de longue durée vous le
reconnaissez le soutien financier de
l'État et des départements est
clairement en recul au regard de la
dynamique de l'expérimentation alors
vous la justifiez en regard d'une
sous-consommation des crédits d'année en
année et vous expliquez par ailleurs
revenir au niveau de financement prévu
il y a 2 ans pourtant c'est bien cette
année que nous sommes alertés par les
acteurs avec notamment la réduction du
financement qui fait craindre à
l'association Territoire zéro chômeur de
longue durée à l'association
gestionnaire du fond mais aussi aux élus
locaux des difficultés pour poursuivre
la montée en charge de l'expérimentation
avec à la fois l'habilitation des
nouveaux territoires mais aussi le
recrutement de nouveaux emplois dans les
entreprises à but d'emploi déjà créé
alors c'est regrettable au vu des
opportunités qu'elles offrent notamment
en terme de dynamique moi j'ai une
pensée particulière pour l'entreprise à
but d'emploi Santi pleine action à Lyon
on se réjouit de l'amendement qui a été
voté en commission des financières de 31
millions d'euros hein de l'écologiste
Marie pochon dans notre groupe notre
question aujourd'hui c'est alors que
paradoxalement l'état enfin le
l'expérimentation est prise en exemple
partout pourquoi est-ce que l'État ne va
pas soutenir et donc maintenir ses
moyens après le 493 vu la dynamique que
crée cette expérimentation merci
Monsieur Mathieu
Marchot merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre après l'embellie de
façade de ces dernières années le nombre
de demandeurs d'emploi sans aucune
activité est en Haos les dernières
prévisions font même état d'une remontée
qui atteindra les 8 % fin 2024 une bien
mauvaise nouvelle dans l'optique du
soidisant plein d'emploi tant vanté par
votre gouvernement alors vous souhaitez
aujourd'hui régulariser des clandestins
afin de répondre aux demandes
d'employeurs qui ne trouveraient pas ces
compétences chez les Français au moment
où le chômage va être encore plus
important au niveau national et qu'il
est déjà massif dans certains de nos
territoires oubliés par les pouvoirs
publics comme dans le Nord où il atteint
près de 9 %. alors Monsieur le ministre
plutôt que le réflexe de faire venir des
travailleurs étrangers que proposez-vous
sur la formation et l'employabilité de
nos concitoyens c'est sur ce sujet que
devrait se focaliser le gouvernement il
trouverait là l'occasion de mener une
politique active de l'emploi sans devoir
ouvrir les vannes de l'immigration
solution de facilité lourde de
conséquences et de danger pour la
cohésion de la société française merci
Madame Josianne cornelou merci Monsieur
le Ministre les crédits dédiés aux
Entreprises Adaptées c'est ont à 465,4
millions d'euros en 2024 il est
également prévu que ce montant soit
complété par une contribution à la gfip
à hauteur de 50 millions d'euros dont
les modalités restent à définir le
difficile déploiement des
expérimentations en EA a été souligné
dans un récent rapport de la cour des
compte qui préconise une réorientation
des crédits pour éviter la confusion
entre financement des EA et soutien aux
démarches engagées pour l'emploi direct
en entreprise classique l'orientation du
gouvernement semble tendre vers une
stratégie de tout inclusif visant à
inciter les personnes en situation de
handicap à occuper un emploi dans le
monde du travail ordinaire pour autant
les crédits alloués dans le budget de
l'État ne répondent pas au besoin de
garantir un service de qualité dans
l'accompagnement des demandeurs d'emploi
en situation de
handicap j'ai envie de vous interroger
sur l'avenir des EA considérant que
cette réduction de financement risque
d'éloigner les personnes en situation de
handicap du marché du travail et de
favoriser l'embauchche de person de
personnes faiblement handicapées par
ailleurs est-il du fond d'accompagnement
à la transformation DEA qui n'a pas été
renouvelée en 2024 je vous remercie
merci et donc monsieur Jean-Philippe
Nilor j'ai oublié Madame Christine
lenabour entre deux pardon elle me fait
déjà des gros yeux alors je m'en
voudrais de pas lui donner la parole et
et on conclura avec Monsieur jean-f
nillor s'il le veut bien
oui avant de de poser ma question je
voulais rassurer tous ceux qui se sont
inquiétés pour les crédits attribués au
réseau d'émission local euh ils ne sont
plus là mais tant pis je vais le dire
quand même donc le président de
l'UNML m'a téléphoné en me disant qu'il
était complètement satisfait et le
bureau également et à la fois du
maintien des crédits de 630 millions
d'euros mais aussi de l'équilibre trouvé
dans le projet de loi plein emploi donc
voilà ça s'est dit j'ai juste une petite
question pouvez-vous nous dire si les
les 300000 Nou veau contrat d'engagement
jeune en 2024 sont bien
euh est-ce que c'est bien un droit
ouvert et que les contrats
supplémentaire s'il y en avait serait
bien financier financé en supplément
merci merci donc pour conclure monsieur
Jean-Philippe
Nilor monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je ne sais pas si le plein
emploi est atteignable en France en
revanche je sais et vous savez qu'il
n'est pas réalisable dans les pays dit
d'outre ma les difficultés sur le le
marché de l'emploi concerne aussi bien
les personnes peu ou pas diplômées qui
sont très nombreuses mais aussi les
personnes les plus
diplômées un/art des jeunes en
Martinique de 15 à 29 ans n'est ni en
emploi ni en formation par exemple le
maldéveloppement et l'absence de volonté
politique ont généré un tissu économique
constitué presque exclusivement de très
petites entreprises qui est incapable
d'absorber cette main d'uvere potentiel
4000 jeunes quittent le territoire
martiniquè chaque année et l'idée qui se
répend c'est que pour trouver du travail
il ne suffit pas de traverser la rue
mais il suffit de traverser l'océan
Atlantique pour
venir en en France trouver du travail
quel moyen monsieur le ministre
comptez-vous déployer de manière
exceptionnelle par rapport à cette
situation exceptionnelle des outrmes
pour rendre crédibles vos orientations
politiques merci monsieur le ministre
vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président pour
répondre à Monsieur di Filippo que je
salue donc à distance nous avons
évidemment bien vu euh les les chiffres
du 3e trimestre 2023 et nous avons vu
aussi que le nombre de défaillance de
d'entreprise revenait au au même niveau
que 2019 pour le le premier point c'est
à la fois un point de vigilance même si
quand on regarde plus précisément les
choses c'est juillet et août qui ont
concentré les chiffres moins bons alors
que septembre marque une inflexion plus
positive et je ne fais pas de prédiction
ni en terme de tendance d'un côté ou de
l'autre je je me contente de dire que
c'est encore un peu instable pour en
tirer des conclusions assez définitives
et que ça do plutôt nous inciter à
pousser et à mobiliser toutes nos
politiques possibles pour que nous
puissions maintenir cette tendance de de
baisse du chômage et de création
d'emploi sur la question des
défaillances d'entreprises nous nous
pensons que 2023 marque aussi la la fin
d'une période pendant laquelle un
certain nombre d'entreprises ont pu
résister à des alléas économiques qui
sont assez classiques à la sortie des
périodes de covid et d'un certain nombre
d'aide massives qui parfois avaient
succiter le le maintien d'entreprise en
activité sans qu'elles en aient
nécessairement les les reins
suffisamment suffisamment solide sur
l'objectif de plein emploi c'est
effectivement un objectif à 5 % c'est
plus que dans bon nombre de pays il y a
un certain nombre d'explications
structurelles qui expliquent par exemple
que nous connaissons les mêmes tensions
de recrutement à 7 % de chômage qu'à 4 %
en Allemagne ou à 3 % aux États-Unis
cela renvoie à la manière dont nous
accompagnons ça renvoie aussi au fait
que pendant une quarantaine d'années le
chômage de masse a très durablement et
parfois très profondément éloigné de
l'emploi un certain nombre d'actifs pour
lesquels les accompagnements sont euh
encore plus nécessaires
pour la question de Monsieur turquois
sur la montée en puissance de France
travail évidemment les systèmes
d'information doivent être calés et
organisés au courant de l'année 2024
pour être tout à fait opérationnel et
ensuite nous nous souhaitons une montée
en puissance sur environ 3 ans t que ça
avait été dit lors du du débat sur le
plein emploi pour généraliser les les
modalités d'accompagnement faire en
sorte que nous puissions aller plus loin
partout mais de manière progressive
puisque nous savons que ce déploiement
ne peut pas se faire de manière
instantanée et à l'échelle d'une nuit
mais c'est un programme de travail que
nous avons élaboré que le haut
commissaire avait présenté euh dans son
rapport de préfiguration et que nous
allons ainsi pouvoir suivre de manière
assez euh euh assez sereine je dois dire
les les crédits nécessaires étant prévus
dans le cadre de la de la LPFP sur les
les questions relatives à à l'Unedic je
l'ai dit et je maintiens l'unedi est
passé d'une situation de de déficit
structurel à hauteur d'un milliard 9 par
an entre 2009 et 2019 l'année 2020 est
une année extrêmement particulière avec
la prise en charge d'un tiers des coûts
euh de l'activité partielle et c'est la
raison principale euh de de la dette
aujourd'hui de l'Unedic mais nous sommes
désormais à à 4,4 milliards d'euros sur
euh les les excédents d'unedic pour 2022
et 2023 et nous considérons que la
participation d'unedic à hauteur de 2
milliards d'euros en 2023 dans la loi de
fin de gestion et à hauteur d'environ
200ard 5 en en 2024 euh sont des euh
participations qui sont soutenables au
vu de la trajectoire d'excédent que nous
connaissons et que ça relève de de
dépenses actives pour permettre
d'avancer et de diminuer encore le
chômage monsieur Darville toujours a
évoqué la situation lave pas je voudrais
dire monsieur le député que en plus des
crédits inscrits en loi de finance
initiale depuis 2017 pour être précis
chaque année çaajoute 110 millions
d'euros de subvention exceptionnell
portter porté à 150 en 2022 que nous
avons encore cette année face à des
difficultés assez structurelles et
malgré l'accompagnement de l'État au
plan de restructuration l' pas tout en
ayant ajouté un certain nombre de
mesures nouvelles notamment sur des
prépasapentissage les promos 1618 nous
avons encore des échanges avec eux pour
voir comment les les accompagner au
mieux et trouver le maximum de stabilité
mais si votre question a été de savoir
si nous sommes attachés à lavepal la
réponse est oui et 1000 fois oui c'est
un réseau qui est utile sur tous les
territoires et une offre de service qui
est particulièrement utile aussi
sur la question des des moyens dédiés à
Pemploi je je n'y reviens pas je l'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure mais les
différents éléments que j'ai annoncé
notamment la contribution lunedic et la
stabilité de la subvention de l'État
permettront à P l'emploi d'avoir des
moyens bien plus importants je je ne
reviens pas sur euh sur la question sur
les sur un certain nombre de mots que
vous avez évoqué madame madame kké dire
condamner à 15h de travail forcé ça
n'est pas le vocabulaire du projet de
loi plein emploi j'en suis désolé ça
n'est pas ça et au contraire nous allons
vers une harmonisation des modes de de
sanction donc vous devriez relire le le
texte et vous seriez certainement
rassuré par rapport à votre intervention
sur territoir Z chumur évoqué par Madame
j'ai euh largement répondu je crois tout
à l'heure euh avec cette chronique que
j'ai annoncé et les ouvertures que nous
avons faites euh j'espère que les
discussions que j'aurai avec Monsieur
Gallois seront plus sereines qu'un
certain nombre d'autres expressions
auxquelles j'ai pu assister qui ne sont
pas forcément productives eu ceux qui me
connaissent savent que euh euh je pas
dire m'insulter mais m'agresser public
m'agresser publiquement n'est jamais la
bonne façon de me convaincre mais ça
n'est pas votre cas et je parlais
d'autres expressions en dehors de cette
enceinte euh mais euh la discussion que
j'aurai avec Monsieur Gallois sera
certainement euh certainement productive
monsieur Marquot vous avez évoqué les
chiffres du chômage n'y reviens pas sur
sur le la deème partie de votre propos
je pense que vous évoquer l'article 3 du
projet de loi
immigration de quoi parlons-nous et et
sans préjuger de ce que seront les
débats au Sénat nous parlons de
personnes qui travaillent de manière
légale qui ont contrat de travail qui
sont déclarés qui payent des impôts qui
payent des cotisations et qui à un
moment de leur vie sont en situation
irrégulière sur le territoire et et la
loi telle qu'elle est écrite aujourd'hui
et nous verrons si le Sénat supprime
l'article si modifier les critères dit
qu'il faudra qu'il faudrait que ces
personnes puissent à la fois justifier
de 3 ans sur le territoire d'une
ancienneté de 8 mois dans un métier qui
relève de la liste des secteurs en
tension ça ça n'est pas un appel d'air
pour qu'il ait appel d'air il faudrait
que un étranger non communautaire en
Afrique en Amérique du Sud en Asie
connaissent ce système connaissent cette
législation se disent qu'il va venir en
France qu'il se maintiennent sur le
territoire de manière irrégulière
pendant 3 ans peut-être 5 si le Sénat
monte à 5 que 8 mois qu'à 8 mois du
terme il trouve un emploi qui appartient
à la liste m en tension elle-même
actualisé tous les 2 ans c'est c'est
audelà c'est pas un appel d' c'est de la
prédiction ça ça n'existe pas et et nous
parlons de gens qui travaillent dans des
secteurs pour lesquels les tensions de
recrutement sont extrêmes et et et dans
des métiers qui sont parfois extrêmement
difficiles la part des étrangers non
communautaires dans l'emploi total en
France c'est moins de 4 % de manière
générale il y a des métiers où c'est 25
% les comis de cuisine et et les femmes
de ménage je dis femmes de ménage au
dessin parce que la part des hommes est
plus que minoritaire et donc nous savons
que sans ces étrangers non
communautaires ces métiers ne
fonctionneraient pas donc pas de lecture
trop rapide si je peux me permettre et
et laissons le Sénat débattre nous
aurons l'occasion d'en débattre en
décembre ici même pour répondre à Madame
cornelou les les crédits que nous avons
inscrit au titre des entreprise adaptées
sont considérés en tout cas je crois
comme suffisants pour garantir la la
soutenabilité ainsi que si on les met en
lien avec la contribution de de la gfip
nous voulons mettre en œuvre
effectivement toutes les mesures dites
emploi des personnes en situation de ap
qui ont été salué compris par l'UNEA
lors lorsqu'elles ont été adoptées dans
la loi plein emploi que vous aurez si
vous le souhaitez à valider dans
quelques jours n nous nous travaillons
sur les entreprises adaptées notamment
pour faciliter le recrutement le fait
par exemple que les les personnes
reconnues comme Invalides par la
Sécurité Sociale et bénéficiire d'une
obligation d'emploi n'est plus à obtenir
à demander obtenir une RQTH pour accéder
à l'employabilité dans des entreprise
adaptées participe aussi à à
l'élargissement des publics et et c'est
dans la loi vous l'avez voté et ça
permettra de faciliter
le le recrutement de de personnes en
situation de de handicap le le fata vous
l'avez dit n'apparaît pas dans la loi de
finance initiale nous travaillons pour
le financer en gestion sur un certain
nombre de fonds de même que nous
inscrivons des actions spécifiques à la
formation des personnes en situation de
handicap et donc à l'accompagnement de
la transformation des modèles dans le
cadre du pic que j'ai évoqué je précise
enfin mais c'est un peu en marge de de
votre question que les les dispositifs
qui sont spécifiques au zat et notamment
au nouveau modèle écon économique des
AAT font l'objet d'une mission
d'inspection que nous avons diligenté
qui devra nous rendre ses préconisations
pour préparer le plfs 2025 puisque ça
sera la date d'entrée en vigueur de de
cette disposition madame l naabour m'a
demandé si ce qui se passe s'il y a plus
de 300000 signatures de de contrat
engagement jeune c'est un droit ouvert
le code de travail le précise d'ailleurs
en 2022 ce sont 320000 contrats qui ont
été signés alors que l'objectif éta à
300000 nousavons pas encore le chiffre
de d'atterrissage pour l'exercice 2023
et enfin pour Monsieur Nilor vous dire
d'abord que les dispositions de la loi
France travail plein emploi France
travail font l'objet d'une déclinaison
territoire par territoire pour l'outreem
que par ailleurs nous avons aussi veillé
à ce que dans le cadre des pactes
régionaux d'investissement dans les
compétences les caractéristiques des
territoires d'outr mè soient pris en
compte et et les collectivité ou région
selon l'organisation sont aujourd'hui
satisfaites de la manière dont on leur
offre une possibilité de bouger par
rapport au cadrees préexistants qui
était beaucoup plus formel et beaucoup
plus uniforme à l'échelle de l'ensemble
du territoire national que nous
développons aussi la formation ouverte à
distance qui permet dans le cadre des
Prix de disposer d'offres de formation y
compris pour des territoires qui parfois
géographiquement sont sont très éloigné
et et que c'est évidemment l'une de nos
de nos priorités absolues que de pouvoir
différencier les politiques et apporter
des réponses les plus efficaces poss
possiblees et enfin monsieur le
Président j'apporter une correction j'ai
dit tout à l'heure que l'évaluation de
dispositifs territoire zé chôur mené par
le professeur lorti sera serait
disponible à l'été24 en réalité la loi
telle qu'elle est écrite prévoit une
période évaluation complète plus
importante donc c'est début début 2025
que nous aurons les résultats
définitifs merci Monsieur ministre merci
pour pour l'ensemble de ces précisions
merci chers collègues pour la qualité de
nos échanges aujourd'hui je vous
rappelle avant de nous quitter notre
prochaine réunion aura lieu mardi
prochain à 17h15 nous aurons l'occasion
et bien d'auditionner Monsieur Frédéric
Pacou don la nomination au fonction donc
de président du conseil d'administration
de l'établissement français du sang est
envisagé en attendant je vous souhaite
une bonne soirée merci à vous
merci